Is this game scary?
For real?
Is this game scary for real?
I can't tell.
It's the... oh my god, this part.
Can you hear that?
It's hitting every scary beat for me.
Oh, hold on, let me fix some of my screen stuff.
Thank you for the donut!
Frubby?
No, Frubby!
Uh, actually, okay, I'm gonna move some stuff around on my computer.
Sorry.
Give me a second, guys.
Give me a second.
Put that there.
Put you guys here.
Into the armpit.
Into the armpit!
Doki barely survived?
No way.
Are you serious?
Only scary if you get immersed.
Don't be scared, Minto.
I'll hold your hand.
Don't touch me!
Hands off!
Sorry, I just woke up, so...
My voice is a little...
Cracky.
You're playing this in the morning.
Yeah, I'm playing it in the morning.
So true, I'm playing it in the morning!
Oh, hold on.
I need a tissue.
Hold on, one second.
Hold on, one second, one second.
One second, one second.
Good morning, Minto.
Good morning, Minto!
It's nighttime in America.
She's playing it in morning.
Um, can I eat a little bit first?
I was gonna eat it before I started, and then...
Um...
And then, uh...
I had to answer some DMs.
Um, I went to the konbini.
And it was super packed.
Just absolutely full of salary people.
And, uh...
Uh, oh my gosh, it was so crazy.
Um...
All I could get was a yogurt.
And I had to fight for that.
Because I had to fight my way...
...back home.
Back through the crowd.
Crowds.
And I got myself an onigiri.
And I got myself a...
Coal...
Cold corn soup.
It says it's delicious cold.
Like, it's supposed to be cold.
So...
I don't know.
I'll try it.
Here.
Hold on.
Okay.
It says, actually, don't sell it hot.
Like, don't...
It's not supposed to be hot.
Doki might have gotten age-restricted for profanity?
Due to excessive hor...
Oh.
No way, really?
Okay, I'll chant...
Or...
No way, really?
I've never...
I don't think I've ever been...
Age-restricted for excessive profanity.
It's her first R.I.T.
stream.
No way!
Not a bit of M.G.'s brain rot seepin' recently.
My brother saw the new Alien movie before me.
So I texted him the next day and he said, Report.
Oh, I said, report, dear brother.
Alright.
Let's try some cold corn soup.
Yummy!
Wait, am I supposed to shake this?
Hold on.
Yes.
Okay, I'm supposed to shake it a little bit.
How was the new Alien movie?
Was it any good?
I think there's bits of corn in it.
Yeah, so I'm gonna shake it to get the corn.
So good?
Bad?
Very good?
I heard it's okay.
That's my consensus right now.
R.L.M.
did it.
I didn't like it though.
Oh, no.
Sometimes, though, I don't agree with them.
There's a new Alien movie?
Yeah, it's like Alien...
Re-Re-Revolution.
Resurrection.
Revolution.
Re-Revel...
Revengeance.
Romulus.
I knew it started with an R.
Wait, what do you mean, clip show movie?
Yeah, I got the R right.
Okay, I'm not gonna continue drinking the corn soup for now.
But I will eat my own again.
Did you know that Cynthia Harrow also sang the ending theme in Castlevania Sympathy of the Night?
I kind of knew that.
But I...
I knew that she sang another song, like other songs for Konami.
But I also was like, I don't think I've heard them before.
So...
Is Ridley in the movie?
In the Alien movie?
No spoilers, though.
What?
Alina, thank you for the Akazuba!
Hi, Minto.
You didn't have to send that.
That was an Akazuba.
You could just say hi in the chat.
I'll hopefully see it.
Oh, Ridley.
Ridley is in Smash Bros.
Whore!
No!
Jay, why are you calling me?
Thank you for the Akazuba.
What am I eating?
I think I'm eating an onigiri.
Sorry for not saying it earlier.
Hello?
Hello!
Hi in the chat.
What's the flavor of onigiri?
It's actually chahan and egg onigiri.
Oh my god.
I keep hearing the police sirens in the background of this.
I don't know if it's too quiet for you guys to hear it.
I keep hearing the police sirens and...
But it's different from police sirens in Japan, right?
The police sirens in Japan are like...
But it's still making me think.
I'm like, oh my gosh.
Is there an accident going on?
Like, what is happening?
Can I get a happy birthday in Japan?
In Japan!
It's my birthday and I'm hoping it'll be a nice one!
Thanks, Oshii!
Of course, John!
Happy birthday!
In Japan!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear John!
Happy birthday!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the pig!
Today's my birthday!
I'm glad to spend that time watching you today.
If I could have a birthday present, it would probably be a watch-along of Iron Eagle, a Top Gun clone that is interesting.
Birds of Denmark!
Hold on, let me write it down.
Iron... oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
Iron Eagle watch-along.
We shall.
I mean, all we had to say was Top Gun clone.
Been streaming a horror game?
No way!
Also, good evening, Minto.
Good evening, Minto!
Wait, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on!
Wait!
You guys, I gotta get my stuff all back together!
I'm gonna have to sing you happy birthday!
Romulus, for vengeance, where the alien is a cyborg who will divide metallic ass.
Happy Birthday to you.
Happy Bomathay to you.
No, I can't remember.
Haya Minto.
I also wanna film ribbon with cool akash blue crown.
Oh wait, I forgot a 0.
No, wait.
Oh!
No!
There is more than enough, thank you!
Happy Birthday to you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy Butter Prince of Denmark.
Happy Birthday to you.
I'm not done with my onigiri, but...
One more bite.
I'm feeling satisfied.
Are you guys ready to start the game?
Thank you!
Hello, hello, hello!
Hello!
Oh!
One thing!
Super chat's from Amelia.
Practically googling whatever whore is.
It's, it's, you know how in Freddy Fazbear, he goes, he goes...
He sings!
He goes, whore.
Oh, wait, I can't say it.
I have to go, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore.
And then he laughs, he goes, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore, whore.
There's also...
There's also speedrunning in this game?
What's up with that?
There was like a thing in the settings.
Enable speedrun timer.
What is that?
I have it... Oh wait, I turned it on before.
What's the timer?
Okay, let's try it.
I'll be honest, I, um...
I, uh...
Um...
What's the word?
I saw Doki playing this, and I was just like, oh, this looks kind of interesting.
Maybe I'll play it myself.
And then I got...
Then I watched Fauna play it.
And I was...
I was like, no, no, no, no, I have to like...
But I was like so sucked in watching her play.
I was like, no, no, I can't spoil myself.
I was like, I have to...
It's like, what is the issue with being a VTuber and also wanting to watch other VTubers?
Because I'm just like...
I'm like, I want to watch a game because I'm interested.
I was like really getting sucked into the story.
But I was like, no, I want to play it now myself.
Speaking of speedruns, congrats on placing third on the hospital scene.
Thank you.
I'm a worldwide streamrunner now.
Spooky don't know for spooky ghost.
Spooky.
Let's do new game.
Optimal experience adjust the slider until you can barely see the center image.
Okay, I'm going to have it around this.
Because actually, it's quite bright in my room.
So it's hard for me to see.
But also, I always find it that like when I stream games, they become too dark.
So for your enjoyment as well.
If it were any darker, I wouldn't be able to see it in my room.
VTubers watching VTubers.
Nice.
You sure you don't mean worldwide Minto?
That's what I said.
Right?
Worldwide Minto.
What do you mean I'm not following rules?
Oh.
Creepy.
A narrative experience.
Frightening.
A balance.
I'll go with frightening.
Worldwide Minto.
Press M to...
Okay.
Oh.
Can't something interesting happen around here for once?
Oh, my head might be in the way, huh?
That is wild.
But it's time to go.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
It's not just a...
Still.
He's drawing his OC.
Okay, hold on.
Let me...
This is the troubles of being chibi.
My head is too large.
And in charge.
Okay, I'll be like this if that's okay with you guys.
I'm like shoved into the corner.
Nobody puts Minto in the corner.
But this should be good so everybody can read.
Pumpkin head.
No!
Isn't there anywhere else I can go?
The pizza was good the first couple of times.
But I really want to do something new.
Who names their kid Oswald?
Sorry to any Oswalds in the chat.
Aw, come on, Oz.
Jeff's can't be the worst place to hang out.
Jeff's?
Every day has been the same all summer long.
I go in, get pizza, stare at the grease-stained yellow walls for hours, and then wait for you to pick me up.
This kid is so ungrateful.
Being able to go to like a pizza place like this every day would be a dream.
What the hell?
Where's the fun in that?
I'm almost glad school's starting tomorrow just so I only have to see that place on the weekends now.
I'm sorry, son.
I know no kid's only option for fun should be hanging around a rundown pizza joint.
But Jeff's is all we got.
It's all we can afford.
Aw.
Yeah, see this kid?
Be grateful.
Your dad's trying.
Bacon, welcome back.
Thank you.
Dude's eyes are glued to the road.
Good driver.
I know, right?
Barely blinks.
Actually, never mind.
He blinks quite a bit.
Stop blinking, Dad.
You're gonna run us off the road.
You know money's been tight since the mill closed.
Once I'm full-time at the corner store.
If the corner store even survives that long.
Everything in this town is dead or dying.
And there's no telling what's closing next.
Oh my gosh, Oswald.
How old are you?
To be thinking like this?
Why can't we go to the next town over where everyone else is moving?
All my friends are there now.
It can't be that hard for Grandma to travel a few miles.
Son, Grandma can barely lift her feet to go a few feet to the bathroom.
Don't be so selfish.
Grandma!
Well, unless her frail bones...
Wait.
What did I just say?
Unless her frail bones...
Strengthen overnight.
Moving is a no-go.
Her bones.
Her frail bones.
Dot, dot, dot.
It means laughing at osteoporosis.
Can't we just pack Grandma up in some bubble wrap?
If only it were that easy.
Even with the mighty strength of bubble wrap, she's still too fragile.
And that's not going to change.
Can't we just kill Grandma?
Speaking of things not changing.
I bet that opossum's still on the corner at the stoplight.
Oh yeah?
Let's make a deal.
If that critter's still there, I'll give you an extra buck for another slice at Jeff's.
Wait.
Like a dead opossum?
Okay.
Oh my god, no!
Still there?
Yes, still dead!
Get, get, get, get, get, get!
Why did they have to zoom in on him?
Things will get better, Oz.
Well, they can't get any worse.
That's the spirit.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm blocking Oswald now!
Oh my god, he's such a little wimp!
What kind of a dad am I if I can't make him happy, let alone afford to feed him more than pizza?
Oh, Dad!
No!
You gave us an extra dollar, we're getting pizza!
I'm sorry things turned out this way, Oswald.
Oh my gosh, this is literally a Disney moment.
Where like...
Where, you know when you watch Disney movies as a kid and you're just like, No!
Ariel is right!
She is, she should be able to leave!
Her dad is in the wrong!
And then when you watch it as an adult and you're just like, Oh no, the dad was right!
Oh no!
The kid is awful!
No!
This is one of those moments where as an adult you're just like, No!
Oh my god!
Tchaikati!
Welcome to Memo Ship!
Thank you so much!
Oh, poor dad.
Well, late again, Dad.
Is this Oswald right here?
Go make friends with these guys!
They look nice.
Remember when this was the place to be?
Totally.
My parents took me here all the time.
I still remember playing in the ball pit.
The ball pit!
And getting ringworm.
Wow, I don't think that's like a happy memory.
Random, but how was the duet of Sally and Jack?
It was so good!
It was like high energy.
Ew.
Probably why it's still roped off.
That and well...
You know.
I know.
Hmm.
A secret ball pit, eh?
Okay, Oswald.
Let's not...
They...
You heard ringworm and were just like...
That's what I want to be a part of.
Prince is absolutely destroying this grandma.
What are you talking about?
Oh my gosh!
Beck, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Beck.
Wooo!
Am I gonna go to the ball pit?
Okay, so we lost out a move and sh...
Uh oh.
Why did we shift to run?
Look at this guy.
We're in the dining area.
Oh my god, my speedrun timer is going!
Ah!
Run, run, run, Oswald!
Wait, I want to explore though.
Free refills.
For water only.
Wish it was orange soda.
Wait!
Oh, I did not...
I did not press E.
Hello?
What's this?
It looks like today's special is a slice of pizza and a drink for $1.50.
The same as every other day.
You look so fed up.
This kid...
This kid is like the oldest looking child I've ever seen in my life.
I don't know.
There's something about him.
He looks like George Costanza with hair.
They don't even have any good flavors in there.
This kid is...
He's such a complainer.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh.
The door is locked.
Okay, so even if I don't press E, sometimes it still opens the...
Um...
And this is the exit.
I promised dad that I'd stay here and...
I'll stay here until he came to get me.
Kid's 14 going on 45.
That's what I'm saying.
You want another slice of cheese and a refill on the orange soda?
Not right now.
Just checking around.
Hey.
Hey, Murphy.
Well, have fun.
Not much to look at other than dust bunnies and cobwebs.
I don't think they bite.
Why does everyone hate this place?
The dust bunnies?
No.
The wolf spiders!
Jeff, those definitely bite.
Oh.
Good luck, then.
Okay.
Thanks, Jeff.
The spiders.
Not wolf spiders.
Those are terrifying.
Is this family still here?
Oh.
They're gone.
Just kidding.
They're still here.
Hello, family.
Let's not talk about that disgusting ball pit anymore.
Oh.
Look for...
Oh, my objective is to look for the ball pit.
Door is locked.
Employees only.
I don't care.
Door is locked.
Look.
They even have vegan pizza.
This place is also huge.
I don't know what this stage is for.
There's never any bands here.
No, no, no, no.
Let's go.
This way first.
Oh.
Okay.
Good.
Oh.
Hey.
It does exist.
It looks kind of gross, but I wonder what Dad would do if I hid and went missing for a while.
Maybe teach him a lesson not to leave me at such a creepy place all day.
Oswald.
Dad.
Oh.
What was that?
Wait.
How do I leave?
Hold on.
I also want to see...
Since this is...
I thought...
I thought the ball pit would be over here, actually.
I've never seen Jeff use this before.
Explains all the stains on the floor.
What are these?
Are these bones?
What is this?
He'll go missing.
All right.
Locked.
I don't think the ball pit is in there, anyway.
What is he...
What is in there?
Oh.
The basement.
Okay.
All this stuff back here.
All right.
Not much here, then.
Okay.
Time to go into the ball pit.
The nasty ringworm ball pit.
It says, do not use.
Why don't they just empty it?
Oh.
It looks like something got painted over here.
I wonder what it is.
Oh.
I can...
You guys can see it, right?
It's Freddy Fazbear.
Oh my gosh.
There's Chica.
Oh my God.
The lights are...
Oh.
I like how the balls move.
I'm playing soccer.
Oh.
Kick the...
I got...
I got an achievement.
Kick the balls into the door frame.
Nice.
Here's hoping I don't get pink eye.
Oh.
I like the transition.
What the...
Oh.
I'm Oswald.
What the...
How's your stinky cat doing?
Show me your kitties.
They're good.
We went to...
Where is this place?
Wait a second.
Wait a darn second.
Oh.
Okay.
I've watched Matt...
Pat's FNAF videos.
Not all of them, but probably more than I would be willing to admit.
And in one of the books, there was a...
Is this the...
Wasn't the ball pit a time travel ball pit?
Wait.
Is this...
Is this game based off the time travel ball pit?
No.
No way.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Look at all these children.
They're so happy.
Excited.
Dad says we're going to the movies later.
Wicked.
What are you saying?
I don't know.
Something about...
People...
Busting ghosts.
Can't remember the title.
What the...
Oh.
I saw that one last week.
Don't get slimed.
That's me.
He's coming.
The characters look like the ones I draw.
Wait.
Is Oswald a prophet?
He's the chosen one.
Why does he draw characters he doesn't even know what they are?
Go.
Oh my god.
This is such a party.
Yo.
Oh my god.
A brown bear.
A blue rabbit.
And some kind of bird girl.
Not the bird girl.
Creepy.
Oh.
But everyone seems to like them.
Oh my god.
Chica has got moves.
They all got moves.
Yeah.
Bonnie is the best.
Do you think he takes requests?
It's an animatronic.
Hey, Bonnie.
Can I program a new song into you?
Look at this girl right here.
She's dancing like she's...
Charlie Brown.
I love this.
This is so good.
This place is bopping.
I heard there's a new game in the arcade.
We should check it out.
I bet it's rad.
I bet I can land the highest score before anyone... before anyone else can?
Oh, dang it.
Mikey.
Yo, dude.
Rad clothes.
Haven't seen a getup like that before.
Thank you.
I like your Future of the Flashback shirt.
That's my favorite old movie.
Oh, that's what Oswald said.
Old?
What are you talking about?
That movie came out like three weeks ago.
Chill out.
He's just messing around.
He's Josh and a...
I'm Mike and that's Chip.
You got a name, kid?
I'm Oswald.
Oswald, like the wizard.
Wait, what's that a reference to?
Dude looks like he came from Gravity Falls.
Right?
The wizard.
Of Oz, of course.
Oh.
Wait, is his name actually Oswald?
Oh, yeah, I saw that one once.
My parents call me Oz.
Guess that's where they got the name from.
Wait, is his name actually Oswald?
How come we've never seen you around, Oz?
I'm, uh...
That's a good question.
Ha, you're a funny guy.
It's okay to be the new kid in town all the time.
The new mill is bringing in a lot of newbies like you...
Oh!
The new mill is bringing in a lot of newbies like you into town.
New?
Brand new steel mill.
My dad works there.
Mike's dad does too.
Heck, I bet that's where your dad got a job.
What?
But...
Chip, dude, you're stressing the newbie out.
Let him have some fun while he settles in.
You wanna play pizza roller with us, Oz?
Yeah.
That sounds fun, but I don't think I'm supposed to be here.
Well, where else would you be?
Wait...
Okay...
I love subtlety.
Come on, man.
I wanna talk about more movies with you.
It's settled then.
Follow us to the arcade.
You snoozey lose.
Um, I don't know what's going on, but...
It couldn't hurt to hang around for a while.
Beats hiding in that gross ball pit.
And who knows when dad'll show up anyway.
Is this the... are they gonna talk about getting pink eye, you think?
I need more tokens!
I think I lost mine in the ball pit!
Henrik!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Technically, this would be Isekai, right?
No.
It's just time travel.
Because this is still the same world.
So it's not Isekai.
Just time travel.
It isn't time travel.
Just Isekai.
No!
You gotta... it's the opposite!
Employees only.
Door is locked.
Oh my god, the kids are going crazy.
This place is bopping.
William Afton, you had such a good thing going.
And you just threw it all away because you wanted to murder children?
Look how much money you were getting!
Pizza!
I want in on this conversation.
Rules for safety.
1.
Don't run.
2.
Don't yell.
We're breaking all the rules.
Is that kid eating macaroni and ketchup pizza?
Yuck.
Pizza snob.
I'm all for the evolution of pizza flavors.
But that's an abomination.
What?
I love macaroni and ketchup.
And then on pizza?
I think it'd be too much carbs.
But macaroni and ketchup is awesome.
It's one of my favorite things.
Clearly, you've never had pineapple pizza.
Pineapple?
On pizza?
When was pineapple on pizza invented, you guys?
When was pineapple on pizza invented?
This is what, the 70s or 80s?
Oh, the humanity!
Oh man, this is some good za!
I love the good za.
This is the good za.
Pizza!
Oh wait, this is where...
Oh, never mind.
We can't go in there.
We gotta go to the arcade.
The good za.
What is this?
Oh wait, is this where Foxy is?
Just Google it.
1962.
He's such a drama queen.
A coupon for Foxy's Piratepalooza.
Freddy Fazbear...
Oh, that vent looks...
Pizza-flavored soda?
I don't even want to begin to imagine how that tastes.
You could leave.
I should take a look around a bit.
No, no, you can end the cycle.
Ozzy!
You can end the cycle!
Do you think they have DDR?
What?
This arcade is huge!
It looks like one of those sliding puzzles.
Huh?
It says I need a game token to play.
I wonder where I could get some.
If I had a voucher, I could redeem it here for prizes.
So retro!
Not really big in 1985 standards, really.
It was so much bigger back then.
Wouldn't it be great to have hamburger on your pizza?
Just imagine it.
All the goodness of a hamburger.
But flat.
But why?
You ever try to hold a huge burger with one hand while you play one of those arcade games?
It's impossible.
All the insides fall out.
But you can hold...
Wait, but you can hold a pizza with one hand.
Huh.
I think you're onto something.
This kid is a genius.
Wait, you're holding...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
He's eating that pizza slice with both hands!
You're ruining...
You're negating your point!
He's...
Wait!
But you just said that you would hold it with one hand!
Unless it's the burger kid that was talking.
Actually, now I'm not sure.
Wait, what was this one?
A bat mallet game?
This doesn't look as fun as the other ones.
Okay, Ozzy.
God, this guy sucks.
I'm sorry.
He's so...
He's so judgy.
Also, just let me know if the music is ever too loud or too quiet.
It's hard for me to gauge with this setup.
So, just let me know.
Dad said he loved this game when he was my age.
It does look pretty fun.
Wow, whoever GGY is has the top score on every game.
They must be really good.
Good.
God gamer.
Gento.
Says I need a game code when I play.
I wonder where I can get some.
Dad said he loved this game when he was a kid.
Okay.
Hey, friends.
Have you ever played Pizza Roller, Oz?
Gregory?
Wait, that's a...
Gregor...
Gregory.
That's a reference to Gregory!
Oh my god, no way.
Not Pizza Roller, but I've seen something like this.
This is the latest and greatest model from Fazbear's.
So I'm not surprised.
Pretty exclusive stuff we got here.
Who, Gregory, is the kid character in Security Breach?
See?
Security Breach, right?
What's Fazbear's?
Ha!
A kid who doesn't know about Fazbear's?
You're a racket, dude.
Here, grab a ball and we'll show you how to play.
You'll go up against me first.
I'll go easy on you.
Maybe.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
So the goal is to score as many points as possible by rolling the balls into the bullseye ring.
There's a ramp on the end that's going to send your balls flying.
So you gotta control your speed.
Check this out.
This is not me.
Show off.
Give it a try, Oz.
Oh my god.
Oh, space.
Oh.
And then press.
Beginner's luck to you, Mike.
Bummer.
My turn.
Wait.
I have to beat this guy.
Wow.
You're pretty good at this, Mike.
No, no, no.
Mike's the best pizza roller player in town.
He's almost too good if you ask me.
Oh, no, no, no.
I have to beat him.
It's not like I try to beat.
I've just been stuck here all summer while my parents were.
But I'll get rusty once we all go back to school.
This music is killing me.
Okay.
Wait.
Here I go.
Oh, no.
I swallowed.
Oh, man.
He's cheating.
School?
You go to Westbrook, too?
Well, duh.
Westbrook is the only school around here.
Okay.
Maybe I'll aim for 50s.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my.
Uh-oh.
You guys.
Extra karaoke the other day.
That was awesome.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's.
Here we're going to have a new teacher this year.
I think her name is Miss Mee-chack.
Oh.
Last ball.
Make it a good roll.
Okay.
I can get him.
You're playing as Mike, right?
Me too.
Yes, of course.
Undefeated.
I hate this kid.
He didn't even go easy on me.
Dude, you didn't have to go that hard.
Just motivating him to try harder next time.
This sucks.
Yeah, I hope William Afton eats him.
How about we play some tag instead?
This place is a little crowded for tag.
That'll give us a chance to show odds around the place.
I say sure!
Rad.
That'll be it first.
Get ready to run!
Wait, who's it?
Don't get caught!
Wait, I'm scared!
The door's locked!
Aren't you gonna run?
Oh, he's it!
Okay, sorry.
My bad.
Run!
Don't get caught!
I'm gonna hide in the vent.
Just kidding.
I'm gonna hide... Where's my other friend?
Oh my god.
It won't budge!
Oh my god!
Run, run, run!
Oh, he got me.
I love...
You guys... I don't know if I'm good at this game.
This place is packed today.
I feel like I couldn't outrun you at all, Chip.
I think you might be right.
Everyone's getting their game on before school.
Ooh.
How about hide and seek, then?
Now that's a game I'm good at.
Here, run!
Find somewhere to hide.
Giving up?
No, no, no, no.
You guys aren't going either.
You should start hiding.
Okay, I'm gonna hide in the ball pit.
I'm gonna go hide in the ball pit.
Never mind.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Um.
Wait.
Don't come and get me yet.
I'm hiding with the crowd!
I'm hiding!
You can't even see me!
This is actually awesome.
Wow!
The ring taco!
Thanks for the Tony gift!
Does this count?
Actually, I can't tell.
Are they gone?
Oh, they're gone.
Uh-oh.
I gotta find some place to hide.
Oh god.
Under the table?
Wait, here.
Maybe?
Why can't I hide anywhere?
Why can't I hide behind the counter?
Hide... in here?
I can't even hide anywhere!
Wait!
Hide under the bench?
Oh my god.
We're talking about the hamburger... hamburger again.
Wait, what's in here?
Oh!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait!
No!
Oswald!
Oswald, no!
Oh, an empty suit!
I bet they never check in there.
Oh no.
Hide in the suit.
No, Ozzy.
Ozzy, Ozzy, please.
Oh, Ozzy.
We're gonna get Golden Freddy'd.
It's me hiding the Golden Freddy suit.
June 1985?
This really is just like that movie.
I hear footsteps.
Better hide!
Hide!
Oh my god.
I can pan the camera.
Oh!
Oh my god!
The meter shows how much noise you are making.
Stay quiet.
Wait, can I hear my mic?
I hope mic didn't hear that.
Gotta hide fast.
He's going.
He gets to go in the vent, but not me.
Okay.
You always hide in the vent, Chip.
Nice try, but I can hear you, Chip.
Whatever.
Did you find Oz yet?
Not yet.
He's quiet.
Unlike you.
Well, I.
Maybe I'll find it first.
We're gonna get spring trapped.
Sus.
They'll never find me.
Oh my god.
Wait, is this how dark the game is?
I can't see any...
What on earth was that thing?
Wait, it's so dark.
Is this how dark the game is?
I'm gonna have to turn up the brightness even more.
I'm glad it didn't see me.
Probably not supposed to be back here.
What's going on?
Oh, okay.
Am I hearing gulping noises?
Gulp, gulp.
Hurry, grab the kids!
The mint of 87.
No!
He's eating everybody.
Hello?
Anyone there?
Chip?
Mike?
Uh oh.
Crap.
Yelling is useless.
Too many people screaming.
Where are they?
Maybe they know what's going on.
So I can hide in here.
Ewww.
Uh, this way?
It won't budge.
Oh gosh.
Why are all the doors in this bad?
Oh, we can play the games now.
Oh, it won't budge.
Oh my god, there's so much screaming.
Okay, time for me to leave too!
Should I just leave?
Yes?
Run, Oswald!
You're so- Oh!
Where do I go?
What do I do?
Wait, you can actually just leave?
See you, dad!
Wait!
No!
Yay!
Maybe?
Oh, sorry.
If you can hear...
Discord.
Congrats for the stream and- Congrats on another successful speedrun.
No!
Actually, I don't know how to get out of this.
So, maybe if I- Oh, here we go.
Skip.
Okay.
Hold on.
Kind of important.
Okay, wait.
So now I have to- Oh gosh.
Now I actually have to speedrun it, don't I?
No!
Try to continue?
Yeah, we'll try it.
Maybe it'll start where we left off, maybe.
Oh, perfect!
Oh, good, good, good!
Okay, so don't leave!
Um, what's this way?
Something's blocking it.
Um, what's the map here?
Oh, so that's security.
Arcade.
So, he came from security, right?
Okay, uh, shows us what is- Okay, the party hallway.
We can go down through there.
Cool.
Back to the gold lane.
Oh wait, it won't budge!
Just kidding.
Okay, now it's also blocked off.
Why is the dining area blocked off?
Like, that doesn't make any sense.
Go!
Run,
children, run!
Okay.
Here we go.
Go!
Oh my god, I'm gonna get trampled!
What's this?
Science has gone a pirate in senior- soon!
No idea what that means, but definitely not checking behind this curtain.
Why couldn't I read that before?
Oh, I can hide here, too.
Okay, good to know.
Wait, how do I leave?
Okay.
Go!
This kid has no survival instincts whatsoever!
So we can't go to the party hallway, for some reason.
We can't go to the kitchen.
We can go to the ball pit.
Is this what everybody's freaking out about?
They look so normal!
I can't go backstage.
Look at them!
We're still partying, everybody!
The party's still here!
Dang, this is a good time!
Oh!
Where are my friends?
I should look for Chip and Mike.
I am!
But where the heck are they?
Some kind of mural.
What weird characters.
Are they under here?
I'm so dedicated to my friends!
Door is locked.
Oh!
We can go through here!
Wow!
Is it asking me to follow it?
Maybe it has Chip and Mike.
Wait, is that his...
Follow the creature.
I can't run in here anymore.
Won't let me.
There's no way someone ate two pizzas while running out of here.
Creepy.
That's your concern?
He was beckoning me.
He was like, come on.
Come here, little eyeswold.
I wanna show you a secret.
Oh, this is confusing.
Okay, so this is investigate, but this is to crawl under.
That's gonna mess me up in the future.
I know it.
Sorry if you can still hear Matara messaging me.
I don't know why sometimes...
Uh...
Sorry.
Oh my god.
Turn off all notifications for Discord.
There we go.
Oh my god!
It didn't even work!
It didn't even work.
Usually when I have OBS on it, like...
It mutes everything, so I'm confused.
Oh!
I think I need to run away.
I think I need to hide.
I think I need to hide!
Eek!
What is this?
What's going on?
What is he saying?
Ew, you can hear like the...
The gasp, the air, the breathing.
Is it gone?
I gotta get out of here.
I hope Chip and Mike are okay.
What is this spam?
Thank you, Dr. Seuss.
That was so funny.
I gotta get out of here.
I hope Chip and Mike are okay.
I mean, I know that they're like your little time travel buddies.
But like you just met these kids.
I think it's a little dramatic.
I'm 13 and that's deep.
Oh!
I think I just heard him come back.
I hear him.
I hear him walking around.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, this is scary!
I can hear him walking around though!
Did you guys hear that?
Okay, the only objective is escape.
So, um...
I guess we forgot about our friends.
I guess we don't care about them.
The door is locked.
Where is that to?
Oh, okay.
That's the arcade.
Oh, what is this?
Um...
What?
It's the possum!
That's so messed up.
Quest, I need to get out.
Why do we have this fan art of me with these two kids that I just met?
We look like we've been friends.
Hold on.
We look like we've been friends since the womb.
I just met these guys!
Like literally 15 minutes ago.
This is ridiculous.
I think Oswald has some attachment issues or something.
Like buddy.
I can hide in here, right?
Oh, I can't hide in there.
What is this room again?
Oh, the party room.
I wanna see what's in here though.
It won't let me go in.
For some reason, it won't let me go in.
And this room is...
Sorry, I'm just trying to get my bearings.
But it's...
It's locked.
And then this room is...
Oh, it won't budge.
That room is the kitchen.
So we can't go into the kitchen.
At all.
I've known them for 15 minutes.
And if anything has happened to them...
Oh shit.
Oh wait.
In here!
Bump it!
Oh my god.
There he is!
Dad!
Oswald, what were you thinking?
Hiding in that nasty old thing?
Didn't you hear me calling you?
Oh no!
Oh my god, no!
He got my dad.
He got my...
Oh.
Eeeeee!
Oh, we got him!
Oh my god, we saved my dad.
Dad, are you okay?
Oh, I thought he was gonna like...
I was gonna have to go back.
Uh oh.
I don't think dad is okay.
Dad, are you okay?
Oh my god, my dad's been possessed.
Oh my god, my dad...
Do you...
Do you say...
Have a good night, guys.
Wait, Jeff, I think something's wrong with my dad!
He looks fine to me.
The dust probably got to your head, kid.
Go home and relax.
Wait!
We're just vanity contacts?
Yeah, obviously.
Night one, Oswald's house.
The longer Oswald runs, the higher chance he'll run and trip.
Wait, really?
What did you do to my dad?
Where are you taking me?
Oh, his eyes glow.
It's so freaky.
How do you even know how to drive?
I mean, he was an adult.
William Afton was an adult.
Oh my god!
Springtrap in the wheel!
My house!
How do you know where I live?
Oh my god, he tripped.
This is so funny.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, we have a cat!
Ooh, the cat does not like him.
I...
I'll just be going to my room for the night now, okay?
Sleepover with Springtrap!
Oh my god!
This is so funny.
Okay, good night, dad!
What's happening?
What should I do?
Oh my god, please!
Why is everybody in the world trying to message me?
Please!
I'm gonna exit.
Out of Discord.
Just close out.
Quit Discord.
There we go.
I'm so sorry.
That always gets me too when I'm like watching a stream and someone... you hear Discord or you hear something and I'm like Oh, you hear Windows?
I always think it's my Windows.
What's happening?
What should I do?
Oh, that's my Windows.
I wasn't in the game.
Oh, I'll call mom!
Maybe she'll know what to do.
Dad always leaves his cell phone at home.
I bet it's in his room.
Okay.
Call mom!
Uh oh.
Why can I hide under my bed?
Why can I do that?
Why do I have so many pictures of Freddy and stuff?
I'm obsessed with these characters!
I don't even know who they are!
ViviCore things are the gifted!
Won't need this fan now that summer's over.
I mean, just because summer's over doesn't mean it's not gonna be hot anymore.
You're silly.
How far do we have to run to trip?
I wonder.
Freddy and Godzilla.
Yeah, we got Godzilla right there.
We have whatever this is.
Dad got me this lava lamp from a yard sale.
Pretty retro.
But I thought it was cool.
Okay.
I've got more important things to do than homework.
So true, kids.
Is this the way we leave?
This is my room.
Okay.
This is Dad's room.
This is the living room?
Dad's room.
Dad's room?
Wait, this is...
Why am I going to the attic when he's Oswald?
Oswald?
This is not where I wanted you to go.
Mom used to rock me to sleep on this when I was a baby.
Freddy and Godzilla.
The two genders.
What are we doing up here?
Looks like there's a battery that got left inside.
Might as well take it with me.
Okay.
And we can hide in this trunk?
Oh my god.
The way he like...
dove in there.
He like so smoothly goes in and out.
This looks like it'll make a lot of noise.
Okay.
Is he closer when I hear the whispers?
Can't tell.
He won't come up here, right?
Yeah, I'm on night one.
Wait, are there five nights?
I'm scared.
Can I hide in the closet?
Okay, I can.
So many numbers.
This must be a phone book.
Okay.
Alright.
Master bedroom.
I went to the opposite way.
Okay.
Wait, what is this room?
Hallway one.
Doesn't really look like a hallway, but okay.
I'm scared.
I don't hear him though.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Um.
Sorry.
He let the man sleep.
I saw dad's phone on the nightstand, but I need to find a way to make that thing leave first.
Maybe I can startle it with a loud noise.
Okay.
Um.
There was the...
The little doll, right?
Who's laughing?
Who's the children laughing in my house?
Okay.
Let's see.
What?
Actually, I'm curious.
What's the date?
Wait, what's under the table?
Why is the table moving?
The year is still the same.
Thanks, calendar.
We keep the board games we play for family fun night here.
We used to go out but now we just play board games at home.
What's wrong with that?
Oswald!
You are so ungrateful!
Is there anything under here?
It's just a breezy table?
I can't tell if this is ambience or if something's coming.
Let's just hide.
Is something coming?
I guess so.
Maybe the current year.
Oh, maybe.
I think it's just ambience.
Oh, we could startle him.
Okay, hold on.
If we startle him with the radio then he'll come out, right?
And then we could just loop back through.
I wonder if it changes...
Oh, see, this.
Which way will he come?
I wonder if it changes...
It probably doesn't change the current month.
But it just came out, this game, right?
So it wouldn't make sense that it says August.
Okay.
I don't know which way he'll come through, though.
The kitchen?
Maybe we go up hallway one.
Oh, my bad.
Open phone!
With the saddest, most out-of-date model imaginable.
I hate Oswald.
He sucks so much.
What are the numbers?
Does dad seriously just remember them all?
Oh, my God.
What are the numbers?
Mom's numbers should be written somewhere in the house.
Okay, we saw the phone book.
Uh...
Close.
Oh, my God.
I have to get out of here.
I'm scared.
Run.
God, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Hide under the bed.
Oh, my God.
Can't tell where he is.
Did he go back to the bedroom?
You think he went back to the bedroom?
Okay.
Wait.
I is inventory, right?
E is inspect.
Can I call 911?
9?
911.
Oh.
I maximized the noise meter.
Unfortunately, 911 services have been suspended in your area for budgetary reasons.
If this is an emergency, please call your local police station.
We're sorry for any inconvenience.
Have a nice day.
I hear you.
Why does it say I hear you?
Who you gonna call?
Well, that's great.
Wait.
Is he gonna come in here?
Did he hear me?
Is that legal?
I don't even think that's legal, right?
Is he gonna come in here?
Did he hear me?
Did he?
Oh my god.
Seeing his shadow opening the door.
That was freaky.
That was so freaky.
Okay.
So it was just hallway 1.
That had the phone books in it, right?
Can you actually call the Ghost Bumper... Bumper?
Ghost Busters number?
The Ghost Bumbers.
I don't know.
What's the Ghost Busters number?
Oh, sorry.
If you hear that, that's my alarm to wake up.
Everything is making noise today.
I'm a little freaked out.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait.
Was that him?
Was that my door or his door?
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
He's walking around.
I hear him.
Oh, I think he's in the dining room?
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Alright.
How do you hear that?
Remember how I said it's hard for me to judge if the...
if...
the volume is too loud or not?
Because for me, it's so loud.
Plumbing, 555, 325, mechanic.
Okay.
Do these numbers work?
That is...
Did he really put his wife in as plumbing?
555, 325.
Wait.
Wife?
You've reached your friendly neighborhood plumber.
What's leaking?
Can you help me?
It's my dad.
Say no more.
Your old man tried to fix the pipes and made it worse, huh?
Well, have him give me a call and I can fix it, kid.
Sounds good?
Wait, it's not...
I think he's gonna come in here.
I think he's gonna hear me.
My dad is leaking.
Yeah, it's not me.
It's my dad.
Um...
Okay, so that phone book didn't work.
Where else...
would it be?
Hmm...
Is this game canon?
I think technically.
I think the books are canon, right?
But FNAF lore is...
Okay, he's in the dining room.
No, sorry.
He's in... Now...
He was in the living room.
Now he's in the dining room.
But yeah, it's very loud for me, so I can hear, like, the footsteps.
I mean, I can...
I can turn it up for you guys if you want.
Where...
Where would it be?
Oh, there's our AU.
Oh, really?
Okay, okay.
My model blocks the noise meter here.
Let's see.
Where can I put myself?
Maybe I have to be over...
My head is too big!
Maybe I just have to be really small.
Yeah, I'll hang out here with you guys up here, okay?
I'll be kinda small, though.
There we go.
This should be alright.
To not block anything.
There's so much...
There's so much on this interface, you know?
So I don't wanna block anything.
Okay.
Let's see.
We haven't gone into the kitchen.
We haven't gone into the basement.
I don't think it would be in the attic.
We didn't see anything.
We saw the doll up there.
Um...
Now, where is he?
I don't hear him.
In here, maybe?
Wait, where's the place to hide?
Oh, that turns that on?
Okay...
Oh, God.
There's nowhere to hide in here.
Wait, there's nowhere to hide in here.
There's a picture of Grandma on the...
Oh, my God.
The cat.
There's a picture of Grandma on the shelf.
She still lives nearby.
Wait, can I go to Grandma?
I don't want Mom coming home to that thing alone.
I hope nothing happens to the cat, you guys.
Does anything happen to the cat?
Please, cat.
I gotta figure out how to save Dad.
Oh, shit.
There's nowhere to hide in here.
Okay, the cat's okay.
Thank you.
Shit.
Oh, shit.
Oh, they give you a little bit of a warning before he comes in, which is really nice.
Oh, my God.
His breathing is so scary.
Why does it look like Springtrap now?
That was my question.
He went into the kitchen.
Okay.
I'm gonna give him a second to get out of the kitchen so we can check in there.
I think we're okay.
What the hell is that sound?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Is he coming?
What's all this yelling?
He may be whiny, but Oz is really damn loyal.
You know what?
True.
You're right.
That is so true.
Oh, my God.
Holy cow.
Oh, jeez.
Hold on.
I'm gonna eat a cough drop.
I have some stuff I need to record later, so I don't want my...
Okay.
Now we go.
Actually, wait.
Where did he go?
Hold on.
Wait.
Where did he go?
Did he go to the...
To the...
Did he go to the hallway or to the living room?
Because if he went to the... He entered...
He went left.
Okay.
Which means he'll come back.
Hmm.
Do you think he'll go to the kitchen though?
No, we don't have time.
He's coming back already.
Oh, my God.
He's going so fast.
Don't go to the kitchen, you son of a gun.
Oh, my God.
Please.
You're camping.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
This is good.
Yeah.
Go.
Okay.
Nice.
Do you need food?
Are you hungry?
Oh, shit.
Shit.
Go.
Go to the basement.
These dusty old boxes.
They've been down here for as long as I can remember.
I got a...
Can I hide in here?
I got... Wait.
What am I getting?
What is all this stuff?
What is all this stuff I'm collecting?
I'm scared.
I hear mice.
Okay.
What am I trying to do?
Trying to find my mom's number.
But I don't know where it is.
Post-its on the fridge.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm just seeing if I can hear him.
I don't think...
I don't think I can.
Check my inventory.
No.
It doesn't have it.
Oh my god.
I didn't mean to do that, but whatever.
Okay.
Squeak.
Oopsie.
Don't come in here.
Do you guys remember the other number?
Oh my god.
The cat.
So cute.
Do you guys remember the other number?
Ugh.
I don't remember it.
There's a contact list option.
Oh!
Oh, that's only the ones that I've called though.
It's only the ones that I've called though.
Hmm.
140.15.
140.85.
Colonel.
Okay.
Maybe we're good.
Don't be in here, sir.
Oh, you can turn the lights on and off.
It makes a little bit of noise.
Is there anywhere to hide in here?
Let's check the post-it.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Please don't.
Take it.
Stop.
I was so close.
This house is...
moderately sized.
You can go to any room you'd like, Springtrap.
Please.
My name is one letter from Bustin.
How do you feel about that, Austin?
How do you feel about that information?
Are you going for a speedrun?
No, I just thought it was funny to have on.
Okay.
I can't...
Oh, the ambiance is too loud for me to hear his footsteps.
But maybe we're good.
Sorry.
Please don't be there.
Okay.
Oh god.
I almost knocked over my mic.
Is this the bridge?
This is Mom's number.
Okay.
Meow, meow, meow.
I love the cat.
Okay, we're going to hide in here.
And we're going to call.
Mom's number.
555-5683.
Hello?
Mom!
It's an emergency!
What's going on?
It's sad!
He's...
Something's wrong!
Okay, I'll be right there.
Hurry!
Perfect!
Oh my god!
Meet Mom.
Okay.
Meet...
That must be Mom.
Oh my god!
Oswald, please.
I think we're okay.
I'm scared.
Actually, wait.
What the...
I don't know where he is.
If he's like in the hallway 2 or something, you know, we could bait him.
Let's just...
Let's just go for it.
Oh my god!
Mom!
Dad's been kidnapped and replaced with...
Kidnapped?
Replaced?
Is this...
I love my...
Honey, don't you know I married him for his glowing eyes?
What are you... You're so silly, Ozzy.
That's why I love your dad.
He's just...
He's just got such beautiful eyes.
Is this some kind of prank, Oswald?
Dad looks fine.
You should know better than to fake an emergency while I'm at work.
Could you, like, talk to him, though?
Like, for two seconds.
The man has not said two words.
But...
Can't you see it?
I see that Dad is fine.
I don't know what's gotten into you, but go to your room and calm down.
I have to get back to the hospital.
Wait...
Maybe you should talk to your husband.
But...
This is so messed up.
Well, it's all up to me, I guess.
Dad has to be stuck in the ball pit.
I gotta get back to Jeff's.
Oh, I do?
Find a way to escape.
Um... We have this weight-resistant mechanism.
And we have a sturdy rope.
I'm thinking...
Can we leave from here?
The latch...
The latch is rusted shut.
I think I can unscrew the bolts though.
Gotta find a screwdriver.
Okay...
Is he coming to my room?
Is he that creepy?
Are you just gonna walk into someone's room?
Screwdriver...
Where haven't we gone exploring so much?
Was there one in the basement and I missed it?
I have a feeling the front door will be locked and he'll be like, I don't know how to unlock it!
I also hate going to the living room because...
Because...
There's nowhere to hide in there.
Attic window...
Hmm...
Hello mouse cursor, sorry.
I'm like half using it.
My room is creepy.
Creepy.
Is he in the ceiling?
Shit.
Yeah, I think he was in the attic.
Here he comes!
I like how he knocks.
Thank you for knocking first.
Thank you.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I did not know that was going to make noise.
I thought it was going to...
I thought...
The drawer...
I thought I was searching the drawer...
Okay.
Maybe in here.
Mom keeps her medical scrubs in here.
Did she leave this battery?
We got another battery.
Interesting.
Oh my god!
What was that?
The cat.
The cat gets around.
Some pictures of my family.
Mom and dad at Halloween.
Grandma holding me as a baby.
I love cat.
Um...
And here.
Lots of clothes in here.
Come on, you're a...
You're a dad!
You don't keep your screwdriver in your bedroom!
Can you pet the cat?
You can't?
Not letting me.
I don't know where he is.
I think he is...
In the hallway?
Dining room?
He's on the left side.
Here he comes!
Maybe...
I'm not a dad, but I keep a screwdriver in my bedroom.
That's what I'm saying!
Okay, he's still over there.
How long is this game, by the way?
Oh my gosh!
He did not give any warning that time.
Let's try the basement.
Four or five hours?
Okay.
So like...
Oh!
A battery!
Oh my god, another battery.
I miss when the furnace was down here.
Oh, I miss when the furnace down here was the scariest thing in this house.
I can't reach the window.
Dad has a ladder around here somewhere.
Oh!
Oh, wait!
A ladder instead, maybe?
Do I have to use a ladder?
Okay.
Damn.
Are you coming in here?
You have no reason to be in here!
Go back to sleep!
Father?
We still have the rope.
So it's either...
Okay.
So we can either find a screwdriver and go back to our room.
Or we can find a...
I can't tell.
Does this pause the game?
Or we can find...
A ladder.
Found the phone number for Jeff's pizza.
555-5333.
Can you guys remember that?
Can you guys remember that for me?
Screwdriver.
No time for games.
Oh, that's right.
This is the...
That's my bad.
Go up into the attic.
We brought it up here once we got Jinx.
Jinx's tail had too many close calls with this rocking chair for mom's liking.
Oh!
Wait.
Two?
Or three?
Oh.
I can't use that here?
I have this rope I found earlier.
I should be strong enough.
Oh my god, I made it!
Wait!
Oh, that was so easy!
Oh, yo!
Okay.
The mill?
Library?
School?
Can I go to any of these places?
Wait, what?
What do you mean library night one?
Go to the ball pit.
Oh.
Yes.
You know, the ball pit that is very famous at the library.
Okay.
Jeff's pizza looks boppin'.
It's still open.
Oh, hi Jeff!
Hey Jeff.
You're here late, kid.
Your parents know you're here?
Uh, yeah.
Dad burnt dinner, so...
Emergency pizza.
What was he making?
Uh... pizza.
Oh, ramen noodles.
As in the microwave kind?
No, you're not supposed to microwave those!
Only recently, you know those ramen noodle cups?
You know?
They never were supposed to be microwaved before.
Only recently did they make quote-unquote microwavable noodle cups.
They started making the cups paper.
Yeah.
Ah, yeah.
Been there.
They forget to add water once the smell...
Oh, and the smell haunts you forever.
Ew, burnt noodle smell.
Can we go in here?
Oh, the arcade!
All the games from the past are still here.
Looks like they've gotten pretty beat up over the years.
None of them look playable with how many parts they're missing.
Awww.
Oh my god.
This is where Burger Kid was!
Microplastics.
Mmm.
What a free tour of Freddy Fazbear's Pizza Kit Factory.
What?
Sounds awesome.
It's so dark in here I can barely see anything.
I don't have the right item for this cabinet.
Oh, okay.
What game?
Game dialogue.
Oh, we got a space age speaker.
Well, we can just go anywhere we feel in this place now?
Okay.
I have an electron gun?
What the hell is that?
What is an electron gun?
These TVs look super cool.
Super old.
Why is Jeff keeping them?
No reason to use the vents here.
I've messed around Jeff's place enough already.
Wait, it's the guy at the counter, Jeff!
Wait, it gives the... what was it?
It gives the arcade games a unique look.
Oh!
Who did you think Jeff was?
I don't know!
Oh!
Oh, this is a party room.
We're collecting things to rebuild the panel.
Not the panel, the arcane machine.
You just realized that?
Well, you know how like sometimes...
I thought it was like maybe a chain.
And like it was just some, you know, some teenager working here.
But he didn't really care.
Door is locked.
Okay, we still can't go into the kitchen.
How mysterious.
What's in the kitchen?
I'm so excited.
His name is on every dialogue box?
I didn't really look.
Okay, into security is also locked.
Okay.
But that's where Phone Guy is.
Ew, Bonnie's face looks so scary.
Don't have the right stuff for this cabin.
Oh, wait.
This one I do.
This one's good to go.
Took out the token system for unlimited play.
Oh my god.
Ozzy is a hacker!
Ozzy!
How do you know how to do this?
Looks like there's still tickets in there too.
I'm glad I've watched Dad repair so many random things over the years.
Okay, let's go!
Don't have the right things for this one.
We have speakers.
Where can speakers go?
Here?
Can't use that here.
Wait.
Is it?
Is it this?
What does the binary say?
Nice.
Stein's here.
So we're gonna...
Some of the stuff we got from home...
So, are we gonna have to go home and get more... or we might have to go to other places, other locations and find scrap?
Interesting.
I'm so sorry, Jeff.
Shouldn't you be doing...
Shouldn't you be at home doing some homework or something?
Kid.
I thought Jeff was just a tired teenager.
You can play the games you fix?
I can?
Let's go play a game.
I forgive you.
Fast food invader!
Wait.
Oh my god.
Toho?
Oh no, it's Toho.
Oh, and I have to... I can't just...
I can't just hold down space.
I have to move and shoot.
Or rather, I can't just hold down space for... I have to continuously press it.
Oh my god.
You hit every...
thing... every...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get the high score.
Screw you, Gregory.
Oh my god.
You miss every shot you don't take.
Or you just miss every shot.
Oh my god.
There's so many.
This is the real gameplay everybody.
Space...
Fast Food Invader Baby.
Come here.
There we go.
Oh my god!
Gregory!
Hamburger!
Kill him.
Oh my god.
Kill!
Burger.
Oh my god.
They're too fast for me.
I gotta get the pizza.
Oh god, it's getting...
Oh, I can only go up so high.
I'm so used to Touhou where I can go to the top of the screen.
Oh gosh.
Oh golly.
Okay.
Come on.
No grazes SMH.
I died?
I can screenshot this?
Oh!
Fun!
I can take a screenshot from Freddy Fazbear's...
Continue?
New music unlock.
Space shooter.
Cool.
Looks like I got some tickets.
Eleven tickets.
What's these?
Heftin with...
Helpulies.
Ten curls!
I felt the burn, yeah.
Dun dun!
Hold on, I want to try that one again.
I didn't get any tickets for it!
It's... it's...
Press E, you guys!
I wonder if it's easier.
Let me try on my laptop one instead.
Because I have both keyboards.
And this is flatter, you know?
Oh god.
But it's harder for me to reach it.
Yeah!
I don't...
Use both keyboards?
Are you a genius?
Hold on, let's try it.
Let's try it.
Don't even think about using auto fire.
Hell no.
Okay, hold on.
Let's use both E's.
I think I'm confusing the system.
Oh my god.
This is actually working.
This is kind of working.
It's working!
It's
insane!
That was awesome.
It didn't give me any more tickets though.
Sorry, Ozzy.
Let's try this one.
Collect the hats.
Oh my god.
I'm Balloon Boy.
Oh, wait.
Huh?
Oh, okay.
I see.
You died.
Sorry.
One more.
Aw, man.
Okay.
Now, I didn't notice the thing at first.
The bombs, you know?
Coming after me.
We gotta wait.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot!
No, no.
What is this Jump King-ish?
Can I be on top of it?
Okay, no.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Okay, nice.
And then we'll wait for that.
Oh, no!
Maybe this side is...
Oh, wait.
Maybe...
No, I don't...
Actually, I think this side is easier.
Okay.
Jump King.
Oh my God.
That was so close!
Leave!
Yippee!
I won!
I got five more tickets.
Nice.
Okay.
The ball pit.
Is there anything else that I haven't collected?
I don't know.
I just want to keep playing games now.
There's one more hat?
Oh, there is?
All this stuff in here.
So creepy.
I don't have the right item for this cabinet.
Okay.
Still got it.
Remember FNAF 3's Balloon Boy minigame?
Try that.
Oh.
Actually...
I don't.
I'm sorry.
I'm like kind of a fake FNAF fan.
Is this my pizza?
Isn't that where I was eating earlier?
Oh.
You know what the stage was for now, Oswald.
Don't act...
Don't act dumb.
Oh.
Sorry.
Can I go into the basement?
Locked.
Okay.
It's still locked.
All right.
Go to the ball pit, baby.
Quickly.
We've had enough of a little bit of a rest, I guess.
Do you?
The faded version of the mural is even creepier.
I really like the ambiance in this game.
It's very good.
Okay.
Now I gotta find Dad.
Oh, God.
What?
Is that a kid crying?
Maybe they need help.
Oswald, you don't...
Sorry.
My computer keeps sending me notifications.
Windows 11 is so annoying.
You don't have to be a savior, Ozzy.
Find the kid.
Oh, they're gone.
Uh-oh.
They're gone.
Due to an incident with our previous Freddy animatronic...
We request that all guests refrain from shining any lasers into the eyes of our performers.
Thank you for your compliance.
Wait.
Where did these three go now?
Oh.
We can go back here.
Oh, there's endoskeletons.
They look even creepier torn apart like this.
Like this shelf with some kind of hunter's trophy display.
A fuse box.
Dad's one-shot.
Someone showed me how to use one of those.
Do I...
I guess...
This wallet belongs to Dad!
He has to be here somewhere.
Oh my God.
We got our Dad's wallet.
Why did it...
Oh my God.
Why does picking up the coins make so much noise?
Find the kid.
It's locked.
Okay.
Where am I, anyway?
Oh, backstage.
Okay.
Wait.
Is someone here?
Why is the ambience so loud all of a sudden?
I don't know.
Okay.
Guess we're good.
Do you guys hear the kid?
That doesn't sound like a real kid.
That sounds like mechanic kid.
Oh my God!
A coin.
Can
I help you?
Sir?
Help me.
I can't get out.
How did you get in there?
Something grabbed me.
Something grabbed me and sucked me in.
It feels like the suit is going to snapshot.
I think I can loosen the bolts with it.
Uh-oh.
A screwdriver.
I'll find one.
Oh, gosh.
If only I had found the screwdriver before.
I'm such an idiot.
Don't check behind the curtain.
Okay.
Who's laughing?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, kid.
Can you, like, be quiet for, like, two seconds?
I thought something was coming.
Maybe not.
Watch.
I opened the door.
Is there going to be...
I thought there'd be someone in here.
Oh, gosh.
Can't open it with it screwed in.
I don't want to be screwed shut like that.
So, I really need to find a screwdriver.
How do I get one, though?
Nope.
You saw what happened last time.
Huh?
Wait.
Does he remember?
Ah!
Wait.
He remembers from the previous ending?
Okay.
Hold on.
Why is there an X by the entrance?
Why is there an X right here?
I wish I could zoom in, but I cannot.
Is it the vent?
Oh, because the vent is locked right now?
Hmm.
Maybe.
Okay.
So, we can't go through the party hallway.
We have to go up.
Okay.
I'm not sure.
Maybe, they're gone.
Who's yelling?
Who's screaming?
Oh, wait.
The door...
Oh, gosh.
All the doors are different now.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I was going to say, I don't hear him crying anymore.
But yes, I do.
Okay.
Just a... Hold on a minute there, buddy.
He's like, can you please at least run.
This door is locked now, too.
Wait, where the heck am I supposed to go?
This door is locked.
This one leads to the kitchen.
Do I come back?
Do I go to my plate?
Wait.
I don't think this would help now.
Do I go back to the present time and then I...
Looks like they were trying to fix this one.
Hope it stays broken forever.
Maybe we go back to the... Oh my god.
What was that?
Is that what those things look like on the inside?
Better than being made of flesh and blood, I guess.
I mean, it's animatronic.
What did you expect there, Ozzy?
Average VTuber reading comprehension?
What do you mean?
It's just... Oh, find the key.
Wait, when did it update to find the key as the objective?
For this room?
Oh, I bet the screwdriver's in there.
Okay.
Okay, you have... Okay.
To be fair, I didn't read it because I thought it was the same thing as before.
Because I checked the door earlier.
If this is the same pizza place, I wonder if Jeff has the same key.
Ah, I see.
Oh wow, so we have to actually go and get the key from Jeff.
Find a way to snap the suit instead.
The faster the kid stops crying, the better.
Yeah, to be fair, that's the only reason why I didn't read it.
Because I thought it... Some of the dialogue stays the same.
Some of it's different.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, this place is safe though.
Yeah, this place is safe though, right?
Jeff, I'm here to commit robbery.
I'm here to commit robbery.
Jeff, do you have a key to the basement?
First the ball pit, now the basement.
Are you that bored kid?
Um, yes.
I just feel like exploring.
Well, let's make a deal.
Just between you and me.
I don't pay for trash and forgot to dump a bag at the mill earlier.
Go take that trash over there.
Out, and I'll give you the key when you get back.
Oh, but take this flashlight.
Gets pretty dark out there.
Thanks, but the battery is pretty low.
Dig around the trash if you run out.
Probably all sorts of interesting things in there.
Okay.
Hold F to reload the battery.
Wait, it's already out?
No way.
I just took it out for two seconds.
Here we go.
You're asking like a ten-year-old to take your trash out.
In the middle of the night?
No.
Dump the trash.
What's this?
Oh, battery.
Battery.
Oh, puzzle.
Wait, no, not yet.
Come on.
I thought I saw one other hand.
What the?
There's eye... Oops, sorry, my bad.
There's eyes here.
I shouldn't have wasted the flashlight's battery.
Okay, you're right.
The mill closed down three years ago.
Almost everything else in this town has been closed since.
It looks like Mickey Mouse.
Rat trap.
Oh, no.
Go back to the mill.
Um...
Rat trap.
Here's my favorite name to say from Beast...
Um, from Breasties.
Uh...
Yuck.
Pretty certain this trash has been sitting here since the mill closed.
Okay, I think that's everything then.
Mill closed.
Nothing else over here.
I guess we're good.
Back to the pizzeria.
This is the longest night ever.
Or am I just slow?
Get the key.
Every time you hear that, the objective is changing.
But you guys are kind of blocking the chat.
This game has just too much going on in all corners, you know?
Lampy, thanks so much for the gifted.
All done.
Thanks, kid.
Saved my aching back.
Here's the key.
As promised.
Thank you.
Look for a screwdriver in the basement.
Perfect.
I wonder...
if we can look in this one as well.
Yeah, this is our corner.
Get out of here, objective.
Oh, nope.
That's not what it is.
There we go.
He's right about finding cool stuff in the trash.
When I was 10, I went to the dumpster diving with my friend, Twinkie.
He went by Porkchop back then.
We got a lamp and a book on electronics.
Is this a reference to something?
I can't tell.
Is this a...
Oh, God.
Oh, no, no.
Huh?
There seems to be a battery underneath.
Okay, awesome.
How many batteries do I have?
For some reason, my inventory is only showing a rat trap.
There's something here, though.
Oh, what's this?
It was there.
You guys saw it, right?
Okay.
Grab the screwdriver.
There we go.
No reason to use the...
Oh, the vents.
Dang it.
Okay.
Grab the screwdriver.
Grab it.
This thing's too rusty to use.
Looks like it's been down here for eight...
For decades.
Oh, okay.
So, we go to the present.
I mean, the past.
These look like the games Dad always talked about.
Okay.
I have to replace.
Back to the future?
No, wait.
No, we're going to the past.
We're going to the past.
Oh.
Classic audio.
The Quasi spill.
All right, kid.
You better still be okay.
I wasn't gone for that long.
You still crying over here?
Yup.
Okay.
Oh God, wait.
The basement is going to be so scary, though.
Are you telling me they haven't changed the key?
Oh my
god, I can barely make out his face in the darkness.
Oh my god, it's so scary.
Oh my god, it's so scary!
What's with these weird spam bots?
I think it's the game.
I think it's Five Nights at Freddy's.
And it's a new game, you know?
Wait, what's that about?
Okay.
Okay, that was just ambience.
Alright, we're good.
Alright.
Yeah, where are these guys anyway?
Okay, the kid is still crying.
Hey kid, I'm here to rescue you.
Maybe.
I don't know, you look pretty snug in there.
Oh my god, it just flopped out!
Phew, thanks.
I thought I was going to be stuck in there forever.
One second I was talking with my friend and then...
Uh oh.
Hide?
That sounds like him.
He might be in danger.
Wait, I thought that was a... I think that's an animatronic!
Come on, we can find him together!
Escort mission?
Wait, I'm not moving.
Never mind, let's get out of here!
You're such a coward!
Wait, I'm looking for my dad!
You haven't seen a tall man wearing a blue shirt, have you?
You mean like an adult?
That's what dads usually are.
Oh my gosh, another spam bot.
What's going on here?
No, I haven't.
Look man, I wish I could help you, but...
Oh god!
To the ball pit!
Phew!
Back in my day, we just used to get hot ladies and fire spam bots.
I know I missed those!
I didn't get a lot of time to look for dad, but I gotta think of a better plan first.
I'm sorry dad, stay safe until I get back!
Go home.
Oh, okay.
Time to go home.
Day 2!
Oswald's house.
Oh my god, recap!
This is so funny.
Is she gonna kiss him?
Are you gonna kiss Springtrap?
This is so funny.
Oh my gosh, dinner with Springtrap!
Let's go!
Such a lovely father.
No!
Was it all a dream?
Look at our cat, so concerned.
I guess I should just start the day then.
You can pet the cat!
The little purrs!
When I went to Ayami's house...
And I met her cats...
She was surprised because Kuma-san was uncharacteristically friendly to me.
I miss my cats so much.
You got to meet Poo?
Yeah, I got to meet Poo-san and Kuma-san.
They were so cute.
The purrs sound so good.
I miss my cats.
Hello, rabbit.
That's not all...
I did to your mom last night, my boy.
No!
What was I gonna say?
Get breakfast.
Okay.
Breaky time!
Anything else we can collect while we're, you know, wandering around?
Let's see.
Oh, there was actually a battery hidden under the clothes in here.
Good thing I dug in deeper this time.
Oh, wow!
So they encourage you to check places multiple times.
Interesting.
Mom's phone.
Looks like there's some text here from yesterday.
Am I gonna be a snoopy little kid?
Oswald seems to be taking things pretty hard lately.
It can't be easy for a kid to understand their dad losing his job.
I'll try to think of something nice to do for him when I pick him up from Jeff's tonight.
Awww.
He's such a good dad.
Mom keeps her medical scrubs in here.
But no batteries, I guess.
It's not go- Where do they eat?
You think the dining- Not the kitchen.
The dining room, right?
We can go up here, even.
Everything is daytime.
I'm so- Not scared.
Here's the ladder, though.
Wait!
Do you see this?
They boarded up the window!
You asshole!
What the hell!
He boarded it up!
These are our old suitcases.
We haven't gone away in a long time, though.
What's that sound?
Is that Springtrap downstairs?
Oh wait, no.
I think that's my footsteps.
I cannot believe that they boarded up the window!
I don't want to go to breakfast, just- Yeah, I still want to keep exploring.
Oh!
My rising sixth grader has risen!
Oh, school starts today!
That's right!
Huh?
The first day of school!
Are you still asleep, young man?
I hope not.
I had the strangest dream about Dad!
Don't worry, Dad's fine.
He's waiting for you in the dining room.
What?
Why are you so surprised about that?
Mom makes the best bacon.
It's a personal policy of mine to never refuse more bacon.
What the f- Mom is about to get Sprungtrapped all night- Stop!
Stop!
Oh my god, don't!
Breakfast is on the dining table.
You should hurry up and eat it before it gets cold.
I'll eat with you tomorrow.
I have an errand to run before work.
Jinx tore up my pink fuzzy robe, so I have to take it to a seamstress before it frays too much.
Something must have spooked her really good last night.
Poor girl.
Oh no.
I don't think it was a dream, Bazzi.
Other than the pizzeria's phone numbers, these notes are gibberish.
Why are they on your fridge then?
Oh no!
That's not where I wanted to go!
Ah!
This game is so funny!
Maybe I'll skip breakfast tonight.
But your dad wanted to eat with you this morning.
Mom!
Um, maybe another morning.
Well, don't forget your lunch so you don't starve today.
I think we should eat breakfast with Papa.
Hello, Dad.
The way he's looking at me.
I'm trying to eat breakfast with you, Dad!
Okay, bye.
Cat.
Anything in here?
Let's explore a little bit more before we go to school.
Can I put a rat trap down here?
I'm not allowed to mess around with the toolbox.
Mom's scared I'd hurt myself.
I'm more scared about the rabbit getting a hold of this.
Oh, a furnace.
Cat.
So we...
Oh my gosh, we have to bring the ladder from all the way up there to all the way down here!
Okay...
Okay, okay.
I do have the rat trap, though.
Jeff needs to buy more of these.
I'm not sure how long I'll play today.
I do have some stuff I need to do later on, so...
Sorry, Dad.
Just a little bit while longer, I guess.
Fancy dishes we only use on holidays.
Dad, you want to play a board game?
Oh, an extra battery!
I'll take it.
What if we had gone in there before we talked to Mom?
The lunch!
Oh, that's right, my lunch.
Thank you.
Good morning, Dad!
My lunch.
Alright.
Go to school.
Bye, Dad!
See you later!
He says...
See you later, son!
See you later!
What is this?
It looks like that game...
What's it called?
Sorry?
Minto Lunch?
We still have Zendrelix vs.
Mecha Zendrelix recorded on the DVR.
Wish I could watch it with Dad right now.
Aww...
Yeah...
Oh, Grandma lives nearby.
My parents didn't want us to move so far away from her.
One of the reasons we stayed in this dead-end town.
Just pick up Grandma and take her with you!
Just literally lift...
Just pick her up!
Just...
Just reach...
Grab her by the waist and just...
Yoink!
You know?
Have a...
day, son!
School!
School day two.
Look at me.
I can't stop thinking about that thing.
Oh my God!
The bully is over here!
I wish I could just run away.
Aww...
Poor Oswald.
Ugh...
Who could eat lunch at a time like this?
JM!
Look at the membership.
Thank you!
You sure that's a good idea, Jet?
Mischievous accomplice.
You can leave if you're gonna be such a chicken.
Wait.
Is that like a TNT?
Is that like a dynamite?
Oh my God.
They're gonna blow up the school!
Hey, underpaid teacher.
What are these descriptions?
Who did that?
Run!
Okay.
I'm just sad Oswald now.
Oh, a battery.
Hope it still has juice.
Teacher!
She's ignoring me.
Animal loving student.
My family has three cats.
Jealous student.
Aww.
I love cats.
Animal loving student.
I have two dogs.
Jealous student.
I have a rabbit.
I love cats.
I hate rabbits.
Okay.
Nobody asked you, Oswald.
You inserted yourself into the conversation to be a little dick.
Get out of here.
Wonder if that kid has any more of these.
Oh.
Smells like fruit?
What did he say?
Wait.
Smells like...
Oh, fresh meat.
Um.
That would be my lunch.
Oswald.
Oh my God.
Thank you for the dodo.
The second story of the book Fazbear Frights 5.
The main character berates a date for being...
What?
Afterwards, he starts to blow up himself.
He feels something moving around inside him and an infanticide springtrap bursts out of his body.
Not a joke.
Come on.
Shalashaska.
Oswald the ocelot has forgotten how to eat.
That was like the one thing you could do right.
Clueless lackey.
Ho, ho, ho.
Good one, Dylan.
Shooting hoops.
Now?
Come on.
These are so funny.
There's a kid in the lockers you should talk to.
Does he...
Is he like a programmer?
A housekeeper?
A hacker?
Settle down, class.
Remember the bell has to ring before you are...
Dismissed.
Thanks, Teach.
Teacher, I don't want to go home.
Yes?
Did you need something, Oswald?
Oh, it's Miss Meecham.
Mrs. Meecham.
I need...
No.
Nothing, Mrs. Meecham.
Sorry.
Wait.
But...
In the past, wasn't she just Miss Meecham?
Did she not take the... the last name?
Hi, family.
Oh, reminiscing student.
My family used to go to the roller rink after the first day of school.
Disappointed student.
At least you got to go.
I'll never get to go now that it's gone.
Eh.
I'd much rather sit at home and play some Field Forge, anyway.
I think you've got it.
You mean start on my Washington Irving essay, don't you?
Stop eavesdropping, teacher.
It's not cool.
What is this music?
I can't believe we actually did work on the first day of school.
I love Field Forge.
Oh, it's Minecraft.
You're right.
Block game.
Huh?
We did work today?
The smoothness of the pixel art hurts my soul.
What do you mean?
I don't mind...
I like it, actually.
I don't mind when some pixel art games are kind of smooth like this, you know?
A back-to-school poster.
The final nail in the coffin for summer vacation.
I kind of like the stylization.
But if you're like, I don't know, a pixel purist, I guess, it's not, you know, what maybe wouldn't be your cup of tea.
Looks like there's a pep rally on Friday.
Should be really fun.
A pep rally?
Is he not in, like, elementary school?
Find the kid with the firecracker.
Hey, you're the firecracker kid!
Sorry, I was reading the objective.
I didn't...
The name's Jet, but that has a nice ring to it, too.
Do you have any more I could borrow?
First off, kid, you can't just borrow a firecracker.
They're kind of one-time use only.
Okay, then can you give me one?
Do you have any idea what these things cost?
Tell you what.
Actually, hold on.
Let me check Discord real quick because I do have some stuff.
Okay.
What I mean is as a pixel artist, I could only imagine how ungodly long it took.
Oh!
Okay, that...
Yes.
That I totally understand.
Look at these twins just walking around.
Oh, my gosh.
Close enough.
Welcome back, Fuwamoko.
Discord has a streamer mode.
I know, but for some reason, it wasn't turning on.
I'm usually at the library after school.
Bring me something I couldn't get anywhere else.
Maybe we can trade.
Okay.
Something...
Oh, my objective is to go home.
Oh, my God.
I drew a picture of my dad.
Have you checked out the new game, Wrestle Quest?
My dad was telling me all about the different wrestlers.
I didn't know much about wrestling going in, but I do now.
Oh, see.
What the...
I overheard the janitor talking to his mom this afternoon.
Must be possessed by a really tidy ghost.
Observant student.
You wouldn't happen to mean a ghost maid, right?
You wouldn't...
You...
What
a ghost maid, huh?
Mint...
Mint in FNAF?
Real?
Oh, my God.
That girl scared me.
Does he know?
This game was made for you.
I'm losing my mind right now.
I have a brilliant idea for a school talent show.
A synchronized water balloon fight performance.
It'll be epic.
Wow, sounds intense.
Why water balloons?
Because we're not allowed to use real bombs.
Why not water balloons?
Touch.
Is this the bathroom?
Nope.
What do you got to say?
You won't believe what happened in science class today.
We tried to make a volcano model and it exploded all over the teacher.
I really made the class erupt with laughter.
Ha...
Nothing divided in half is nothing.
Probably a math textbook.
Okay.
Divide by zero.
Voucher validator.
Okay, cool.
So there is stuff in here as well for the...
For the machines.
What is something that is...
He...
Oh my gosh.
A box.
Something that he wouldn't be able to get.
I know I have to go home but...
I want to look around as well.
We need more trophies than the high school's team.
Oh, sorry.
We have more trophies than the high school's team.
Yeah, they're for kickball but still.
Dylan's pulled this once and they had to evacuate the entire school.
He got in so much trouble.
Mm-hmm.
I won't be sharing any of my new sketches anymore.
Don't want to see those monsters at school.
How does he know what they are though, you know?
God, the children sometimes look so scary.
Like, look at her.
Her eyes are just...
There's not a thought behind that brain.
I mean, there's not a thought in that brain.
Please cheer us on in the regional volleyball tournament.
I know we can win it all this year.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Ghost made.
Fish eyes.
No soul.
Mr. Principal!
Okay, I can just go into your office?
If I squint, I can see my house from here.
I used to do that every time.
Anytime I would...
Even if I was like...
on the other side of the country.
If I went on a tall place...
I would be like...
Haha!
I can see my house from here!
What's with the timer?
Is this a speed run?
No!
I just keep forgetting to turn it off.
But also, it's helping me keep track of how long I've been playing, so...
Actually, I kind of don't mind it.
A framed article...
from the school newspaper.
The headline is about the time we won a kickball tournament.
Speed running a game for the first time sounds...
crazy.
Nothing useful.
Just garbage.
Is there anything else in the backpack I could use?
Are you still a jealous student?
An animal-loving student?
Yes.
Okay.
What about you?
Oh.
Athletic student?
Basketball?
At a time like this?
Froggy chair!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Okay.
This is world record pace.
I think you're right.
Oh.
How about you read a book on how not to be a loser?
Ha!
Come on, guys.
Let's stop wasting time on this nerd.
Are you okay, nerd?
Little nerd?
Are you okay, little nerd?
Don't listen to them.
Dylan's just jealous because you know how to read.
Damn!
Ozzy!
No!
He's just jealous because he knows how to read.
Haha.
Thank you.
The bullies picked on me for reading at my old school, too.
Well, then.
They must be pretty stupid.
I read a ton of sci-fi.
What are you reading?
Ancient Greek mythology.
Oh.
Uh.
I've been meaning to get around to that one.
Okay.
Ozwell with the Riz.
Haha.
It's not much different from science fiction, really.
Oh.
It's all about being brave during impossible situations.
She's a Percy Jackson kid.
I could never get...
I was a maze runner kid.
You know?
Couldn't get into Percy Jackson.
Hmm.
Well, if you ever want to read something with pictures, I'd be happy to lend you a comic.
Oh.
If you like art, maybe you'll actually have a use for this thing.
Sorry.
I'm like eating my corn soup.
No.
I actually have not seen the maze runner movies yet.
Maybe I should.
Kubo.
Thanks for four months.
Thank you.
Choo choo.
Cowabunga.
I was a Top Gun kid.
Haha.
There's a certain NPC in the school that has like some special dog dialogue that you might like.
I don't know where it is or what day it's on, but...
Shark.
Okay.
I think I went through all the rooms that I could, so maybe it's a different day.
I was helping my grandpa clear out some junk yesterday and found his old sketchbook.
There's some neat drawings in there.
Uh-oh.
It's going to be a Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear jump scare.
Oh my gosh.
It said it's Chica.
Wait.
Your grandpa is...
Your grandpa is William Afton.
Why is she starting to smell bad?
I don't know.
Excuse me?
Why is she starting to smell bad?
What is that smell?
Tech 2 noticed the smell, too.
It's not just me.
What?
Why is she starting to smell bad, you guys?
Company issue number 85.
Inner torso repairs.
Investigations are to be delayed.
No eating around Chica.
No behavior.
August.
Chica is making garbage nests.
Make employees aware all garbage needs to be taken out before closing.
Why is she so sentient?
Disable smelling protocol during daytime to avoid Chica stealing food.
Kids cry if they see the endo mouth.
Oh.
Do not attempt to play Bonnie's guitar.
Any voice box malfunctions must be reported to upper management.
Adjust hug.
I'm sorry.
Fractured a kid's back again?
How many times has it been?
Why is that even a protocol?
Adjusting.
Yet again.
Whoa.
Glue hat to head.
Kids keep stealing it.
Uppers don't care about safety.
Jaws are still unpredictable with the new models.
Why does he keep screaming?
Keep bright flashes away from Freddy's sight.
Sends him into a frenzy and blows him away.
Close the circuits.
No camera flashes.
So if I see the Freddy animatronic, I should flash my flashlight.
Is what I'm getting.
I don't know quite what the Bonnie one means, but the Chica one, I...
So I have to not have food?
Remember the dark eyes are watching.
Okay.
So if I'm in the dark.
That's when I'm in trouble around Freddy.
AI programming causing Freddy to stalk partygoers by guarding doors.
Tech 2 is on assignment.
Tech 2 knows something.
Where is he?
Freddy keeps trying to remove his own head.
Tech 2 on assignment.
No...
No raves?
Freddy is a little...
Huh?
Tech pulled fifth no-show in a row.
Note for later.
Random stuff starts to appear in places it doesn't belong.
Encourage others to be vigilant.
This is a health code violation.
Not that the uppers care.
Tech 2 slacking.
I know, right?
More random stuff appears and everything begins to form in a circular pile.
The pile is clearly formed with an intent... with an indent in the center.
Chica will bring stolen food to the pile and eat it.
Oh, maybe that's how you destroy the food.
She will distract her by leaving food or something and then she takes it and goes eat it.
Recent security update fried the AI.
Wait, so are we going to have to watch out for Chica, Freddy, Bonnie, and Springtrap all at the same time?
These locations are not that big.
Recent security update fried the AI.
Chica stuck in preservation protocol as a self-soothing mechanism at night during security rounds.
It bites.
Keep fingers away.
Tech 2 missing?
Maybe this should be in bigger font.
Someone got into the Cupcake's voice box and programmed it to growl.
Tech 2 has been asked to investigate.
Tech 2 is missing!
Stuff on the guitars.
New guitar model.
It's 4v1.
No!
Bonnie's strings now break at least once a week.
Change them even if they are still intact to avoid snapping on stage.
Save old ones as backup.
Helper management requested all old strings to be dumped off-site due to pending lawsuit.
Tech 2...
What?
Just use, like, string.
Tech 2 was asked to dump them all by the...
Oh, at the mill by EOD.
End of day.
Probably don't want to get sued after electrocution incident.
Poor kid.
Oh my god.
Detailed animatronic eye diagram.
Cool.
Detailed layer...
Suit layer diagram.
Cool.
Some little stickers.
Okay.
This is Freddy.
What is this one?
Bonnie?
Maybe?
No way.
He used to be some kind of technician.
So they're just doodles and notes from his old job.
He didn't want to talk about it, though.
I was supposed to throw it away, but I didn't want to waste the paper, you know?
Haha.
Yeah.
I'm Gabriel, by the way.
Or Gabrielle.
Wait.
Gabrielle?
No.
I'm Oswald.
This is an interesting sketchbook, Gabrielle.
Thanks.
Okay.
Put that sketchbook to good use.
Thank you.
See you.
Wait.
If we go to the middle...
Do you think we can find stuff here?
Gabrielle.
Oh my god.
Look.
It's the little thing that we couldn't tell...
I couldn't tell...
Oh my gosh.
There's...
Lots of...
Someone made, like, FNAF OCs and just dumped them all here.
Yuck.
Pretty certain this trash has been here since the mill closed.
Yeah.
The mill closed down three years ago.
Those are from FNAF 6.
Trash and the gang?
Wait.
Are those actual FNAF characters?
Hahaha.
Wait.
They're actually...
Hold on.
They're actual FNAF characters?
That's so cute.
They're the trash gang.
Oh.
Hi.
Wow.
What do you know?
Show me your kitty.
Thanks for the fine kitty.
Thank...
Oh.
My bad.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's see.
I know we have to go home.
But he did say meet at the library.
Okay.
Let's just see what's at the library.
Hmm.
It's starting to get dark out.
Uh-oh.
Dad gets a little funky at night.
Okay.
The kid's not even here.
What a liar.
Okay.
I's Walt's house.
I'm home.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Night two.
All right.
Time to go back to Jeff's.
I think I have a plan now.
Got to get out of here first.
Find a way to escape.
I think so.
I might call it here.
I know it's a little bit early.
But next time, I will...
Oh.
I'm going to wake up earlier and play through every...
Actually, I don't know.
Hold on.
Let me see what time my meeting's at.
I can't remember if my meeting is...
Oh.
One second.
What time it's at.
I can't remember.
Oh.
Never mind.
I have more time than I thought.
Okay.
I can go, like, another hour.
Cool.
Never mind.
Don't leave.
I can go, like, another hour.
All right.
So, we're going to have to go get the ladder.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I think I just heard him.
Oh.
Okay.
I got to turn up the volume a little bit.
Oh, I hear him.
He's on the left side.
Cool.
I got it.
Get out of here.
Mom let Mint use the computer for another hour.
Woo hoo.
Yeah.
Of course, it's boarded up.
I don't know what I actually did on that.
Unexpected.
Dang it.
So rude.
How do I get this ladder downstairs?
Oh, a ladder!
Oh god.
Okay.
Maybe it's okay.
You still have the screwdriver.
My inventory is all messed up.
My inventory is glitched so I can't see what I have.
Yes, I do!
Oh, I can use it in my room, can't I?
But the...
I don't have the rope anymore.
Unless I can just drop.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Looks like dad... I just realized.
Looks like dad gave me his last buck from the opossum, but...
There's no money left.
How does he buy his lunch?
Object 1 out of 5.
When our town's retro shop got the new Mecha Zendrillix robot, dad promised he'd take me to go see it.
I wanted one so badly, but dad didn't have any money.
I bought it a few weeks later and I thought I'd never see it again.
Turns out dad was the one who bought it.
He worked overtime every day for weeks just so he could surprise me.
I was so happy.
This kid...
needs to be more grateful.
Okay.
Maybe I can...
do the one in my room then.
Let's try it.
Oh, gosh.
Please don't be down here.
Okay.
Um...
Screwdriver.
Eek!
Oh, yo!
That way it works!
I mean, he's trying to save his dad from a possession.
Yeah, I know.
But before that...
He was like, dad, I don't want to go to this pizza place every day.
I'm so sick of the pizza place.
Be grateful you have somewhere to go.
And your dad buys you toys and stuff.
Hey, Jeff.
Don't cause me trouble.
Thank you!
Oh, there's people here actually.
Enraged customer.
It's taking forever to get my pizza.
I swear the longer I wait, the more I can hear the rats in the walls.
Like, what if the kitchen has rats?
Even worse, what if the cooks are rats?
Don't tell me to calm down.
You know I have...
Moosophobia?
What's a Moosophobia?
Seems distracted.
And paranoid.
Um... I don't think she's that paranoid.
I think she's actually quite valid.
This place is really gross.
Is there anything else in here that I can grab?
Ratatouille.
We got some more things.
So let's...
Maybe the vouch?
No.
Oh!
Puzzle matrix.
Oh, it's this one!
Solve the puzzle.
Oh...
Do I have to?
Do I have to solve it?
Oh, gosh.
Guys, we're gonna be here for a while.
What is... What is this?
What even part of his body is that?
Oh, gosh.
Oh!
The rest of the stream is here.
Aw, man.
Maybe another time, Oz.
Well, you know...
Ozzy, we're busy.
We don't have time for this, you know?
We're busy, Oswald.
We're busy.
If I had a voucher, I could redeem it here for a prize.
That rocket ship looks so cool.
Why am I fixing these anyway?
Actually, don't... Not quite sure why.
I didn't even eat my lunch!
Oh!
That was binary!
What did that say?
Hmm...
Interesting... Interesting... Interesting...
Shoot the space balloons!
Oh!
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god!
Oh, I can move!
Wait...
Oh, this is really weird.
Wait... Oh, this is weird.
Okay, hold on.
I don't like this one.
It's like you move like this...
Oh my god.
And you shoot like this...
And you...
Oh, I don't like this one.
It's so hard to move!
Good game.
Don't have the right stuff for this one.
I think we're out of stuff actually.
I would be able to tell...
If...
If I could see my inventory.
Why is my game bugged?
Big kid?
What?
What does that mean?
What about my tickets though?
I have tickets.
Somewhere.
What about my tickets?
Trade the tickets in the pass for a voucher.
Oh!
That one makes sense.
Well...
Who am I trading them to?
Everybody's gone.
The place is possessed.
OK.
Go to the ball pit.
Posse will get a job repairing and restoring arcade machines.
If he makes it out alive...
Oh!
Trip over five times!
I finally got it.
The voice that I heard before.
Wonder where it came from.
What voice?
Wait.
What are you talking about?
The lights are out!
Gotta figure out how to get them back on!
No, no, no.
Oh!
That is a good question, isn't it?
Oswald.
How do we...
How do we turn the lights on?
Wasn't there a fuse box?
Yes, there was a fuse box in the backstage.
I used to hate slide puzzles too.
The trick is to concentrate on just the top row and left side.
Works every time.
Really?
Should we try it out?
I'm avoiding my problems!
Yeah!
Let's go!
This way.
Woo!
Okay.
Let's try it.
So solve...
Sorry.
The top is nearly solved.
Oh!
Oh, I think I went the wrong way.
I think I went the wrong way.
You guys can't say...
Mint...
When you know that I'm bad at the slide puzzles.
You guys can't say that when you guys know that I'm bad at the slide puzzles.
This is how we started, right?
Like this?
Wait.
Actually, I can't tell.
Maybe...
I remember the time I learned how to do sliding puzzles just to 100% go strict and probably forgot how to do sliding puzzles.
Wait.
Do I have to do a...
Yeah!
See?
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
Wait.
If I...
Hold on.
Wait.
If I...
I think we're back where we started.
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh.
I wish I could use my mouse.
I hate using the watch to...
Hold on.
Holding.
Hold.
Not...
How do we get it out of the corner?
It looks like his teeth are really close to his eyes.
Easy...
It's so easy about it.
Wait.
This is the left bottom left.
Let's
go kids over first...
And...
Am I sitting?
Is the thing in context?
She wasn't kidding about the puzzles.
I'm never ever in my afterlife been good with the sliding puzzles.
Please understand.
It looks so close.
I'm just rotating them around in circles at this point.
How do I get it out of the corner?
Rotate each corner to move the pieces you want closer.
Top, middle, to top.
Two hours.
Sometimes I
just...
Gosh, you say all you have to do is figure out the top and the left side.
That's like figuring out part of the puzzle.
That's the issue.
I don't know how to figure it out!
Just figure it out!
Why can't I use a number pad?
Okay, awesome.
My left hand was getting tired.
I'm just gonna brute force it.
Oh no, I think I ruined it.
All you have to do is draw the rest of the outline.
So
close!
We're so close!
I didn't listen to you.
You said solve the top right.
I'm doing the bottom.
Or you were like, the top left, I'm doing the bottom right.
Order though!
Okay, done.
What's the...
Oh, this side.
How do I get it up there?
I don't understand how these puzzles work at all!
Oh no!
I'll never understand!
My brain doesn't comprehend!
Gotta be honest, Mint, I can't solve this either.
Nah, I'd puzzle.
I almost have it.
Do I actually?
I'm close?
You're really close.
Wait, I am?
Counterclockwise on the bottom right four tiles.
Bottom left are good too?
Oh wait, this one is in the correct spot, isn't it?
You know one thing that was funny?
I was thinking of...
Oh, what's that game called?
There was a game that I was like, oh, maybe I'll try this.
I'll stream this one.
It's called...
The Observer?
The Watcher?
It's only puzzle games.
It's only puzzles.
And I was like...
The Witness!
The Wit...
Synonyms are hard, you guys.
Oh gosh, it's almost been 10 minutes and I've been stupid!
I can't believe it!
I can't figure this out!
My best time will be my only time.
I'm having a time.
Pretty funny that they just assume that you're having a best time.
Want me to give it step-by-step?
Yeah!
What's the step-by-step?
What if you did some super exclusive fan service right now to spite the VOD watchers who will skip the entire slide puzzle section?
But yeah, but you can't put it in the timestamp.
Or you can't put a timestamp in the comments.
Do the witness parody.
The Looker.
What would I...
What would you want me to do?
This is only for real VOD watchers.
This is only for real ones who watch me struggle.
You know?
This is for all the real ones who are just like, I'll watch Mint do whatever.
I'll watch...
You can't clip it.
You can't put a time in the comments.
What should I do though?
Counterclockwise.
Wait, hold on.
The bottom for one more time.
Okay.
Sorry.
The music is driving me a little bit crazy.
Okay.
Counter.
Wait.
Nope.
Until when?
When do I stop?
Now move the eyes to the middle right.
I can't.
Wait.
Oh.
Rotate the bottom one more time.
What?
I'm so confused.
You say rotate but until here?
How does that get me...
What?
I'm so confused.
Try to move the left ear to the middle left.
And the eyes to the top left.
You need to get the eyes rotating ahead of the right ear.
Ahead of the...
Ahead of the ear?
Would this be right?
Wait.
No.
Uh.
This is so crazy.
I don't know what to do.
Why would you...
Why?
I don't even know what...
I don't even know what fanservice is.
I don't even know.
I don't even know...
What do you...
What do you even want from me?
I thought we were just hanging out.
I thought we were just bros, man.
Don't be weird.
We're just bros.
Bros.
Bros give each other fan service?
What would your Oshii do?
My Oshii... oh wait, I just realized I forgot to, um, unpin this comment.
My Oshii... she would probably... well, my Oshii has already called me gross and disgusting, so...
Here's my take.
From the top right, 1, 2, 3 is correct.
Try to visualize the following.
Wait, 13... wait, 13x first roll.
1, 2... wait, x2x second roll.
You emo, you're really trying to help, I appreciate you so much.
You do a lot with your bros.
Like what?
Big ham!
Fan service is acapella settling nanya.
Shut the fuck up.
Shut the hell up.
My brain is frying, you guys.
Put the eyes above the ear.
And rotate into place.
And then we just do a big rotate!
Here it is, the big roll!
It's the big roll!
We're doing it!
We're doing the big roll!
I hate this game.
I would rather go back into the darkness of a possessed pizzeria.
Next time...
I'm gonna hire somebody to...
You know what, I should have...
I'm gonna hire somebody that will sit under my desk for every stream that I do.
And if a game happens to have a slide puzzle...
You know, bro, the best bro service would be winning the slide puzzle, bro.
They're gonna hide under my desk and anytime that there's a slide puzzle, they're gonna secretly climb out.
And they're gonna do the puzzle for me.
And I will...
I'll just react.
And then they'll go crawl back under their hole.
You could send your...
Send your applications.
Show me your slide puzzle credentials.
Show me your best scores, everybody.
Okay.
Oh gosh, here we go.
Why does he jump in so enthusiastically?
It kind of annoys me.
So that's the fan service.
I don't know what to do.
For fan service.
I still can't see anything.
I still can't even see anything.
Actually, I don't remember what it was at before.
Okay, here we go.
But for the fuse...
I think I hear somebody.
Oh god.
Just pull it.
Okay.
We did it.
Oh wait, are they gonna come in here?
Oh god, wait.
I think they're gonna come in here.
Um...
Hide!
Someone coming in here?
It's, um...
It's Springtrap!
IDK how to solve a slide puzzle and I just move the pieces randomly until I chance upon the answer.
So I feel so validated right now.
See?
You can watch Minto stream and feel validated.
Okay, we gotta find dad.
But we have to also wait for Springtrap to leave.
More like SlideTrap.
Okay, I think maybe I'm okay.
There is...
What's this?
Oh, token slide!
Nice.
And we have a screwdriver so we can now start venting, can't we?
That will give us...
Okay.
More hiding spots, I think.
I'm scared.
What's that?
Oh, no no no no!
Don't try to play his thing.
There's a battery on the shelf!
Nice.
Thank goodness we knew where the fuse box was, why don't we?
There's another kid!
Oh my god, it updated our objective from find dad to find a kid!
Real fan service is your existence.
I'm a fan of you.
It's not bad.
But...
Stab me!
Ghost has no reason to run away from robots?
It's because...
Oh my god.
I'm a human child in this game.
It was so loud.
Holy cow.
Where was the kid?
Oh...
Hold on.
I actually...
I can actually hear someone coming.
I can't tell how many of them are walking around right now, you know what I mean?
Maybe we're okay.
Trying to find a child in this place.
It should be open now.
I can vent.
Fast travel!
Alright,
let's go.
Thank you!
Do you care how to describe solving side puzzles?
Just big loop, small loop, big loop, looping direction, doesn't matter what.
I see.
Alright, so...
We're in the storage.
Oh, and it shows!
Wow!
Nice.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
You can see the...
My... what's it called?
Stem...
How do I leave?
There we go, let's try this way.
Door's locked.
Okay.
All these doors are still locked.
What about the party hallway?
Where's that crying coming from?
Not again!
Are you kidding me?
No way.
No, no, no, no!
Hide, hide, hide, hide!
No, no, hide, hide!
I can't tell if something's coming or not.
So the lights just turn off periodically, this is so evil!
Wait, the music is not helping, I can't hear anything.
Okay, I'm just gonna leave.
Here we go.
Who's crying?
From the kitchen?
Where?
My lunch!
Oh my god.
Oh, she's gonna eat my lunch.
She's gonna eat it in her trash pile.
That's right.
She loves to eat the lunch.
Oh, she left.
Does that thing even have a stomach?
How did it smell my lunch from that far away?
Oh my god, the rat.
Shut the hell up, rat.
There's definitely a kid in the kitchen.
But I can't get to them until I lure that thing back to its weird nest.
If it wants food, maybe I can get a slice of pizza from Jeff.
Talk to Jeff.
Let's get out of here.
No way!
That scared me so bad!
Ghost children!
Why were there ghost children there?
What is going on?
What is happening?
Pizza!
Jeff, pizza!
Holy moly.
Oh.
Hey, Jeff.
Do you have any extra slices of pizza that you could get me?
Sorry, kid.
You know things have been tough lately.
You want something?
You gotta buy it.
Oh.
Okay.
Find a way to cause a distraction.
I'm a...
Oswald's turning to a life of crime!
What do I do now?
I can't afford to buy anything.
If I could just borrow... You can't just borrow a slice of pizza from the kitchen!
Why don't you trap a rat?
I'm sure it'll eat it.
Five-finger discount time?
No!
If I could just borrow a slice from the kitchen...
I have this random rat trap I found.
I bet a rat chase will get Jeff away from the door for sure.
Um...
This guy, like, borrows... Quote-unquote borrows everything.
He's like... He wanted to borrow the firecracker.
Oh, wait.
Let's go fix that other machine.
Which one was it?
Not this one.
Oh, nice.
Uh...
Oh, my bad.
Um...
Where did it go?
Token slot?
Huh?
Wait, huh?
Didn't I play this one already?
Wait, what just happened?
Huh?
Wait, what?
But that was fixing the game!
Wait, what what?
Oh, I think it... I accidentally...
There we go.
That was weird.
There's a secret in this?
Oh, yeah.
Some people did say there was an extra hat.
What was it?
Let's try it.
I'm not stalling.
I'm just playing a different game.
This is technically part of the game.
You know, I'm not stalling to do other things in the game because...
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
There we go.
Wait...
You guys might have to... Oh, dang it!
Why did I... Why did I...
I knew I wouldn't have been able to make that.
I don't know why I thought...
Where's the extra hat?
Um...
Do I, like, knock it off my head?
Is it the hat that I'm wearing?
Um...
Or is it, like...
Oh, my bad.
Or is it, like, hidden?
Why are the platforms...
so hard to...
Okay.
No way.
Did I miss my opportunity to get the hat?
It's... It's... It's purple guy!
How would I...
Okay.
Let's try it again.
Aw, man.
Hold on.
We can get it this time.
William Afton.
Oh, shoot.
I thought the hat was going to be invisible on the platform.
I didn't think it was going to be actually...
Oh, my God.
Please.
I didn't think it was going to be actually...
Like, it's a separate room.
Is this the only game with a secret?
Um...
Purple man.
I tried.
You guys, I tried!
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ba-da-da-da-doo.
Ba-da-da-da-da-doo.
At least I don't mind the song so much in this one.
Ha-ha-ha.
Oh, wow.
How did I get that?
I'm gaming?
I think I'm gaming?
I think I'm so good at this now?
Oh.
Brr-brr-brr-brr-brr-brr-brr.
Um...
Is this... wait.
Okay.
What?
Oh, I'm so stupid.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice!
I actually don't know...
This is Balloon Boy, isn't it?
I actually don't know his lore.
He's just a little silly.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go get this balloon boy.
Balloon.
I mean, this hat.
What was the return plan?
I don't really know.
That's a W for me.
Rescue the children?
Okay.
One child.
Child ghetto.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
No, no, no, I hate this.
Wait, I hate this so much.
Leap!
Oh, sorry children!
Sorry children!
Okay, okay, okay.
Rescue the children.
Okay.
This one stresses me out already.
This one already stresses me out.
I don't like it.
I don't like it!
Oh my god!
Oh, shoot.
We did it!
Wait, what do you mean I failed the save?
Hide
me!
Oh, we ate one!
Oh, one got eaten.
No way!
How is that even possible?
How is this even possible then?
Oh, shoot.
How is this even possible?
Oh my god.
Don't get eaten!
Little kid!
I found the strat.
Yippee!
I saved all the children!
Save them.
Creepy.
I got some tickets more.
That one, we've beat...
We've beat all of them.
Ish.
We've beat almost all of them.
I wonder...
Let's see.
Hold on.
I...
Okay.
I'm scared to go...
Wait, what?
What am I doing now?
Oh, find a way to cause a distraction.
That's right.
Let's get a rat.
Where can I find a rat at?
Um...
There are rats in here?
Rats down here.
What's this?
This puddle looks like it's been here for a while.
Hope it doesn't seep into my shoes.
Ew.
Is there rats down here?
Okay.
Maybe...
I just have to go back to the...
What's this one?
Maybe I just have to go back to the past and get that one rat.
Maybe it has to be a very specific rat.
Yeah.
There was a rat in the house too.
But I don't think I should go back to my house.
I could never get dad to tell me what this place was like when he was a kid.
Now I see why.
Yeah.
Everybody's traumatized.
Let's be careful in here.
Eee.
It was in the kitchen room, right?
In here.
Oh, I hear something in there but the door won't...
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
This next room.
Over.
Oh.
I hope something doesn't scare me because I think I might actually...
I have to go to the bathroom.
I'm just saying.
Okay.
How do I get this rat?
Sprint.
Not sure how just yet but I think having a pocket...
Oh.
A pocket rat will come in handy.
Glad I found this trap.
I don't think it will come out while I'm standing here though.
Better leave so it comes back.
Get a pocket rat.
Oh.
Snap.
Eee.
That was so cheap.
Great Scott.
That's a big rat.
He'll scare somebody for sure.
All right.
Oh, God.
He's coming.
I saw that.
I saw...
Did you see the door?
Let's run.
Let's just run for it.
Okay.
What was that?
What's that sound?
Okay.
We're good.
Everything's fine.
You're here late, kid.
We don't sell slices after lunch.
So if you want pizza, you gotta buy a whole pizza.
Oh.
I'm good for now.
Where's the pizza?
Really?
Social butterfly.
I think I'm talking to too many people.
Now, where does he want me...
Where should I release the rat?
Over here?
Oh, here.
By her.
Probably.
This should be enough to distract Jeff.
Down,
huh?
You picked the wrong place, pal.
The kitchen should be free now.
Just have to sneak in, grab a pizza, and hurry out before Jeff comes.
Okay.
Sneaking mission go.
Sorry, Jeff.
I'll try to find a way to pay you back.
What else is in here, though?
Oh.
This is a huge freezer.
Don't want to get locked inside.
There's a little thing...
Pulley thing there, too.
Lure the bird out is the objective.
That's so funny.
Sorry.
It's a bird.
Jeff is just trying to make a living, man.
Jeff is just trying to live.
He's just trying to live.
Okay.
So, we lure Chica, and then we...
And then we get the kid, I guess.
Oh, these balls here are looking...
Oh, they're wooden balls.
I was going to say...
I was going to say, they're looking a little...
Gross.
Let's lure Chica.
Wait, I can hear somebody.
I can't tell if it's...
I need to lure that thing out first.
Okay.
Pizza here.
Oh, wait.
Where does this go?
Where does this go to?
Where am I?
The basement!
Wow.
That's handy.
Okay.
Good to know.
All right.
Let's go back.
Wait.
That's not Chica.
That's the spring trap.
You hear him?
That's not Chica.
Okay.
Are you tired?
Don't you get it?
I think we're good now.
Where... so I put it on the plate here?
But like... oh, here we go.
Not exactly how I imagined feeding a chicken.
Oh my god, no!
Hide, please!
Hide!
Here she comes!
Okay, okay.
When she starts chowing down.
Make a run for it!
Oh, a coin.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, the phone is ringing.
Phone guy?!
There's no kid in here.
Phone guy!
Yeah, no, shoot.
I hear someone down below.
I feel like I could get swallowed by that open.
Wait, there's no kid in here though.
I got baited?
Oh, there's a kid!
Oh my god!
It's Mike!
Is it gone?
For now.
Let's go to the exit.
Okay.
My game just saved.
Wait, map?
From here.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Aeee!
Bow, bow, bow...
Is he gonna to come down this way?
Wait, did he just go to the entrance?
Wait!
I think I just heard him leave.
How did you live?
How did you survive?
Aren't you coming?
No, I'm looking for my dad.
He's wearing a blue shirt and has brown hair.
Have you seen him?
No.
Have you seen Chip?
We were in the arcade when the power went out.
No, I haven't.
Do you think he's...
Mikey,
you coward!
Mikey, you little shit!
How could you?
Mikey!
Mikey, how could you do this to me?
Oh, the objective was to escape.
Oh no!
Wait, I should have left!
Oh,
I didn't realize I was supposed to go to the ball pit.
That's my fault.
I thought I was just going to run.
Wait... How... Wait, how far back am I?
Oh, okay, okay.
This isn't so bad.
This could be worse.
I think we can go in.
I think we can go in there now.
Auto-save saved your butt for real.
Okay.
Screw you, Mikey!
The way he just stares at his friend leaving him.
Abandoning him is so sad.
Go, go, go!
Escape!
Don't trip.
Don't trip, Mikey.
I mean Ozzy.
Ozzy.
I'm getting the children confused.
Man,
that was way too close.
Why can't I find him?
Where haven't I looked yet?
Time to go home.
Ozzy, Ozzy, Oz.
Yay!
Day 3!
Nice.
Apparently slipped.
Why can't I...
What does it want now?
Lady Winter, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
I'm going to pet my cat.
Well guys, I think that's where I will leave it off for today.
Probably pick it back up later this week.
What's today?
It's Monday night for you guys.
Tuesday morning for me.
Tomorrow, I have an off collab.
So I will be technically streaming, but not on my channel.
It will be on the other channel.
I don't know if they've announced it yet or not.
But...
I'm going to talk to her and see if we're good to announce it.
Which other channel?
Her channel!
Her channel.
So... yeah.
But I'll post it as soon as possible.
Like ASAP.
ASAP, I will post it.
I'm not a big FNAF fan, but this game looks fun and I love the sprite work in it.
Thanks for the stream.
Yeah!
Thanks, Irlen!
Me too.
So fun.
A woman?
Yeah.
A pretty lady.
She's...
She's a fiery lady.
I'm looking at the right side of the screen and I see Foxy there.
Or at least something Foxy's shot of.
But... yeah.
We'll be hanging out and we got some stuff to do.
Some stuff to...
to plant.
So...
Thank you guys for watching.
I've got to take a shower and get ready for my meeting.
But I will see you guys.
Um...
Tomorrow.
At the collab, hopefully.
Hopefully.
Right?
I hope.
But like I said, I'll post it on Twitter.
I'll post it.
I'm sorry that I haven't got my schedule out yet.
I will try and do that.
Today.
Like ASAP.
Hopefully after my meeting.
Or something.
I'll get it done.
My cat's so needy.
Takezoro!
Thanks for the five you did!
Thank you!
Um...
I know that I haven't been very good with posting schedules lately.
I'm so sorry.
Um...
Japan is really kind of kicking my butt.
But...
BUT!
I'm glad that I can stream at least even a little bit.
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
Um...
I know that I've been having to stream less.
But...
You know...
One was an off-collab and then the next one's an off-collab too.
So...
You know...
I'm still streaming.
Just in different places.
Thanks for the stream.
You're welcome.
Keep on dreaming, buddy.
Ain't gonna happen, but just keep on dreaming, buddy.
Keep on dreaming.
Don't let go of your dreams.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you so much!
And I'll see you next time!
Meow!
Bye-bye!
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
So I can...
I didn't think of a fanservice thing, though.
Mmm...
Um...
Hey, buddy.
You...
Mmm...
No!
Ducky, thanks for the buy gifted!
Bye!
Take your meds!
Bye!!!
What the?
Oh!